and is brought to you today by your
cable or satellite provider
and now on book tv it's your opportunity
to talk live with professors cornell
west and robert george professor west
has written many books including race
matters and brother west living out loud
professor george's books include making
men moral and conscience and its enemies
robert george when did you first meet
the man sitting next to you
must have met in the 1990s a little
while after brother cornell
uh came to princeton
and we were together in
faculty seminars i think under the
auspices of the center for human values
but we didn't know each other very well
we would just say hello to each other we
interacted a bit in the seminars
we began teaching together in
2007 and there's a whole story behind
that i don't know if you want me to go
into
that kind of detail but that's that's
when our teaching partnership and our
friendship really began 2000 teaching
partnership began professor west there
was a brother named andrew who's named
last month
he studied with both of them he had set
up a magazine i think it was called
green
green light he was teaching my course on
public intellectuals erasmus david hume
and matthew arnold edward zaid he was
taking a course from you with civil
liberties civil liberties
and he asked
me who i would like to have dialogue
with who was a conservative i said oh
there's one brother i'd love to i
haven't had a chance to have a chance to
engage in dialogue with
and it's robbie george so we got
together we had about a 45-minute
dialogue based on the recording the
recording was over brother andrew left
we continued to talk for at least two or
three hours walked back to the car
continued to talk
and said
we've got to continue this conversation
and we've been going for 9 11 to 12
years all around the country teaching
at princeton
primarily what's the name of our course
adventures of ideas adventurous
north whitehead's a great great classic
but we've had a wonderful time i've
learned so much from brother robbie and
vice versa and this is his family uh
just magnificent cynthia and the others
and he's been so good to me my family we
just love to engage the subject matter
we know the truth is bigger than us we
know goodness is bigger than us and
beauty is certainly bigger than us but
we quest for it we aspire to it i'll
tell you a bit more about uh about our
meeting or uh our meeting that began the
teaching partnership uh the green light
the magazine that andrew perlmutter and
other students were beginning yeah a
green light green bag no it's not like
from the last paragraph of uh that's got
physio yeah that's right so they wanted
to have as a feature in each issue
uh an interview of one professor by
another professor
so uh andrew was a religion major as i
would yeah that's right uh so so uh for
the very first issue they contacted
brother cornell and said we'd like you
to do the interview who would you like
to interview and he kindly said that he
would like to interview
me so technically what that was was not
a conversation it was uh an interview it
ended up of course being a very deep
conversation
so um so andrew came to me then
and said professor george
um we're starting a magazine we'd like
to have an interview feature in each
issue we'd like uh the first interview
to uh be uh feature brother wes cornell
west as the interviewer and and we told
him that he could interview anybody he
wanted and and he said he'd like to
interview you would you be willing to be
interviewed by professor west
and i said andrew let me get this
straight
you went to professor west and said he
could interview anybody he wanted
and he said he'd like to interview me
andrew said that's right and i said well
i want you to send a message back to
professor west i want you to tell
professor west that professor george
says but it is i who should be seeking
baptism from you
and unfortunately brother andrew was a
brilliant kid and a religion major did
not catch that reference
to john the baptist's baptism of jesus
in the in the jordan river so so he
responded by saying huh
and i said well just just tell him that
he'll he'll understand what i'm talking
about he said okay i'll tell him that
but will you do it and i said of course
i'll do it so uh so we had that
wonderful dialogue which was recorded
and then we went on and on and on after
that all the way down
to the car and i'm holding my um
my hand on the car latch for about a
half hour while we're continuing to
shout away and then just a couple of
weeks after that
uh we got the senior members of the
faculty got an
a letter from the dean of the college
nancy malkiel
saying we want to encourage more of our
senior
faculty members to teach freshman
seminars
we want more interaction between our uh
our top
more established scholars and the
freshmen
so when i saw that letter uh and uh on a
request that we that we teach these
seminars
it immediately occurred to me that well
you know what we should do is just have
that conversation that cornell and i
were having that's right with 16
wonderful
bright enthusiastic princeton freshmen
why only 16 why'd you limit it
well we didn't have a program that's
princeton's rule and then there's a
story behind that as well of course
because once the word got out that we
were going to be teaching this together
there was there was a big
there's a big demand and uh
we had to read all the essays to see
which particular 16 we would choose and
then after that we decided we just
aren't going to try to do that we would
just let the registrar's office choose
randomly and then the registrar's office
decided that they would do it on a first
come first serve basis and students were
supposed to sign up or
they could start signing up at seven
o'clock on a particular morning and of
course at seven o'clock that morning
they crashed the computer system so uh
that's true but that's a beautiful thing
about princeton i should say even as one
who teaches at harvard i think princeton
has had the highest quality
undergraduate education in terms of
hands-on
16 students there
each senior writes a senior thesis still
focused very much on the undergrads and
harvard and yale and berkeley and
chicago and howard university and other
wonderful places but when it comes to
high quality undergraduate education
princeton's number one i must say once
you come back well i
cornell west and robert george we've
invited you on to talk about your books
but why haven't you written a book
together
well we we've talked about that a lot
and we have both harvard university uh
press and princeton university press who
are interested in having us
do that for them and we both very much
like to do it the trouble is you got two
really busy guys with a lot of
responsibility and obligations we have
traveled around the country doing uh
doing public dialogues and conversations
and so forth so we will get to it we
will we haven't uh we haven't yet now
we've done some some interviews together
we recently had one in um was it the
washington times or the washington
examiner quite a lengthy one as a matter
of fact oh absolutely and also in the
princeton magazine that's right
princeton alumni well one of the things
you do in your book professor george the
clash of orthodoxies
is you allow other scholars to rebut you
in your and your views
well i think that's uh that's how
philosophy works that's how education
works that's how learning works that's
how scholarship
proceeds especially though not
exclusively
in the humanities and social sciences
we learn by
giving an argument providing reasons
producing evidence
then letting a critic respond to that
this is how
intellectual life in the western
tradition and certainly the field of
philosophy began with with socrates
engaging
critics
uh
subjecting their views to criticism and
permitting them to subject his views to
criticism cornell and i are
old-fashioned socratic scholars we both
believe in that kind of education and
you both spend a lot of time talking
about socrates and aristotle absolutely
in your box very much so you know
erasmus used to say saint socrates pray
for me
he's a christian both of us are
christians we understand the richness of
the socratic legacy of athens tied to
the prophetic legacy of jerusalem which
is to say that self-interrogation
self-questioning what the greeks call pi
day
p-a-i-d-e-i-a which is deep education
not cheap schooling that kind of
transformative
dialogue that makes us examine our basic
assumptions and presuppositions we talk
about this all the time how do we learn
how to die you die when you give up a
certain set of assumptions and
presuppositions and become more mature
more willing to grow and develop because
you're learning how to live as you learn
how to die
education is very much a matter of
trying to kill the prejudices the
presuppositions the narrow dogmas the
narrow ways in which you view the world
in order to be expensive knowing you're
still going to end up finite fallible
endless progress endless possibility
always the in the name of what you're
after would would it be fair to say that
your books
are all about self-examination in a way
but but self-esteem nation on socratic
sense but also the prophetic legacy
jerusalem because as a christian
uh uh it's more than just
self-examination it's a matter of
self-surrender it's a matter of
self-emptying it's a matter of
self-giving so when jesus is on that
cross he's just not examining himself
he's giving himself he's emptying
himself at the deepest level take this
love and see what you can do with it
because i love you so so that what you
actually get is socratic legacy of
self-examination but the
legacies of jerusalem judaism
christianity muslim muslim islam and so
forth is really one of self-surrendering
to something bigger than you
so that you get that fusion of socratic
self-examination and prophetic witness
because you you can't love unless you
take a risk you can't love unless you're
vulnerable you can't love unless you do
what brother bravo and i try to do what
given our
disagreements
we know as human beings and this
person's main image of god that there's
some human overlap
so that whatever the barriers are we're
going to find that overlap even as we
honestly wrestle with the various issues
that we uh
that we fight over in a way one of the
points that i uh make to our students
is to
render yourself capable of
self-surrender which as a christian i
agree with cornell is our ultimate uh
obligation and indeed fulfillment that's
the great paradox of christianity that
our fulfillment is in surrendering
ourselves in being christ-like
but i stress that to get there
to the point where you are capable of
that
you need self-mastery
you need to be able to control your own
wayward desires
your own wants your own passions put
them under the control of reason plato
teaches us that in the well-ordered soul
reason is in charge
and appetite or passion is under the
control of reason when things are
disordered
passion is in charge and reason is
instrumentalized and harnessed to the
goal
of creating rationalizations for
activity that can only really harm us
and harm others now how do we get to
self-mastery here's where
self-examination the examined life
liberal arts education comes in
we get to self-mastery
by subjecting ourselves to criticism
interrogating our own assumptions
putting on the table even our most
cherished our deepest even identity
forming
beliefs
and that's a big challenge because
people don't want to do that
it's difficult for any of us to do that
we human beings being human
we tend to wrap our emotions around our
convictions
which is good in a way because if we
didn't do that we would never be
motivated to act for worthy causes for
justice for the common good for human
rights for human dignity and yet if we
wrap our emotions too tightly around our
convictions we become dogmatists
we
abandon any possibility of subjecting
ourselves our assumptions our arguments
to criticism we become incapable of
being what we should all aspire to be
and that is interrogators of
ourselves well in your book making men
moral
you write
laws cannot make men moral only men can
do that and they can do it only by
freely choosing to do the morally right
thing for the right reason
professor west is that something you
agree with oh absolutely absolutely i
think what brother
robbie's getting at is something so
badly needed in our present day because
we get this we live in this
market-driven society obsessed with
spectacle and image and position and
money
and status that you lose quality of
character quality of soul what we could
call soul craft and soul craft has to do
with
the ways of being human you choose as it
relates to various virtues and as it
relates to various values so when
brother robbie talks about moral
character that's something that
that the market can't teach you is that
something that
being a professional can't teach you
there's something deeper going on it's
got to shape and mold you it's
fundamentally about that self-surrender
it's about love it's about integrity
honesty decency generosity i mean when
you talk about self-mastery in regard to
socrates one of the great questions of
western civilization is always why did
socrates never cry
and jesus never laughed
socrates never crying man he puts a
primacy on self-mastery rightly so
but self-mastery is not the proper
response to your mother's funeral
but tears
it's the proper response
because you love
jesus wept because he loves so socrates
never cries so there's a love for wisdom
that's important but you've got to out
socratize socrates and make your way to
jerusalem jerusalem begins with tears
the tears of a hated people the tears of
a persecuted deep people are tears of an
enslaved people of jews vis-a-vis
pharaoh
and jesus weeps for jerusalem he weeps
for lazarus precisely because he loves
so so that the self-mastery still has a
role but it's not enough
to self-surrender
that's where the tears come because
tears shatters the numbness inside of
one's heart shatters callousness
shatters indifference and what lets one
know lo and behold
you a human being like everybody else
you calling for help like everybody else
and as you know my brother because i
know you attend black churches and
congratulations on 25 years of working
in this magnificent place
but when you go to those black churches
the best of those black churches is what
we are people who've been hated for 400
years but we teach in the world so much
about how to love
as john coltrane loves supreme that's
martin luther king jr love ethic that's
james bond love silk essays that is
high quality soul craft
brother robbie
linked in his own wake in his own
tradition to that i linked my own weight
to her own tradition even given our
disagreements on the oppressed issue you
know any human being
ultimately faces the question
what's the point of my life yeah yes
what's worth living for what's worth
doing that's right what's worthwhile
now
every human being is going to be in a
certain culture it's going to be formed
by that culture is going to have to act
in the context of that
culture is going to have to react
to what is coming at him or her in that
in that culture and for just about any
every human being they're going to be
powerful temptations
because it's easy to believe in fact we
live in a culture that reinforces our
belief
that what's worth living for is status
prestige social standing
wealth
power now those are not in themselves
bad things and i think it's a mistake to
condemn those as if they were bad in
themselves wealth isn't bad in itself
power isn't bad in itself depends on how
you use those things
but to make them what's fundamental to
make them the ultimate goal is to fail
to see what human life is really all
about and what is worthwhile in human
life
and this is our mission for ourselves
and for our students
to make people understand that integrity
honor
decency
these are what are truly fundamental
these are what make life worth living
this is what we should aspire to
not in itself for their own sakes wealth
or glory or power or influence or status
or social standing now that's a big
challenge
for young men and women who are super
high achievers and we've been blessed to
teach those kinds of students our entire
lives at places like princeton and
harvard
those students are going somewhere
and they've got big futures
in investment banking as lawyers in
medicine and other fields and they can
do a lot of good in all of those fields
but they really face powerful
temptations to believe
that it is standing it is status it is
influence it is power it is wealth it is
being looked up to by other people that
is what really matters
and you really haven't gotten there and
nobody's finally there through our
entire lives
but you haven't even gotten close to
being there
until
you've got the strength of character the
self-mastery
to be willing for the sake of what's
right what's good what's true
to sacrifice it all
now you try telling a princeton student
or a harvard student or a william
student or a saint olaf student really
any student these days in this culture
you might be called on
to give all that up to stand up for what
you believe in
you may arrive at a view if you're truly
open-minded if you're truly willing to
listen if you truly engage you might
arrive at a set of opinions
that marks you as an outsider
as a bad guy as somebody to be rejected
now are you going to have the integrity
to stand for that knowing that it could
cost you professionally absolutely in
terms of further education social
standing your friends and things like
that when we think back to socrates
cornell and i we remember how he died
he had him locked
the hemlock they made him drink the
hemlock he was a martyr
indicted by his fellow citizens he
refused to go silent on the truth even
when the truth was unpopular
exactly didn't want to hear it line 24a
and plato's apology
parhesia was the cause of my
unpopularity plain speaking french
speech
fearless speech
unintimidated speech
that's plain speech and it can get you
in deep trouble i mean brother robbie i
mean he gets in a lot of deep trouble i
do and conservative circles partly just
hanging out with me
but in addition to that that he's
willing to
deal with unpopularity
based on his own commitment to his
understanding of what it is to be a
person of integrity
and and i try to do that within my own
progressive circles as well because it's
not a question
of popularity we reject the chains of
conformity
we want to be non-conformist we want to
be in the world and not of the world we
want to be over against the world
we want to be tied to
a kingdom that is so much greater and
grander than this world i'll learn to
shiloh baptist church under willie p
cook my great pastor if the kingdom of
god is within you then everywhere you go
you ought to leave a little heaven
behind
now that kingdom of god means what in
this world is a world of coldness
cruelty domination oppression hatred
envy resentment that's the dominant ways
of the world
what you're going to do now that you're
in it
how you're going to come to terms with
it
be non-conformist not out of
self-righteousness and we keep trying to
keep each other accountable there
because you can always fade into a
self-righteousness and not acknowledge
the self-critical character of your own
stances that you take you know the
problem for human beings generally
is that we tend to be tribal
and tribalism today
is a big problem
all around the world in our culture
and our culture
uh and uh
people will expect you to play for the
team
but if your own convictions your own
reflections your own inquiries
lead you
to a view
that puts you outside
the team on this one yeah
and you publicly dissent well you can be
in very big trouble that doesn't that
that's true whether you're progressive
like brother cornell or conservative
like me in the uh in the in the most
recent presidential campaign i
could not in the end bring myself to
vote for donald trump i just regarded
him as morally unfit to be president of
the united states i don't want to
litigate that right here i'm just using
this as an example
and uh
because i
wouldn't play for the team
i got a lot of heat from
the team well you want to elect hillary
clinton well actually i didn't want to
elect hillary clinton i opposed her too
i saw of her as if anything worse than
donald trump that got a lot of pushback
of course from other people but cornell
found himself in the same position
when he refused
to support hillary clinton after she had
gotten the nomination having supported
bernie sanders brother bernie yeah he
got the same heat i was getting on the
conservative side from
the liberals from the progressive aside
from from the left but he wouldn't yield
you know he he he wouldn't say okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna stay silent on this for
the team
between the two of you how many times
have you been arrested
have been arrested yeah i've been going
to jail he's he's the jail goer
now i haven't i have offered i don't
know how many times to bail you out now
that's true though exactly when i was in
uh the last time was it down in uh
ferguson i think it was or maybe in st
louis or whatever it was that it was
true and i do like i got a call from my
brother how much money do you need
he knows i'm broke of the 10th
financially sometimes but it was but
that's just the kind of you know love
and respect and support that he
that he has though but i i've i've quit
can't tell you actually i'll tell you a
wonderful story about this
so when uh was it cornell was it 2016 i
believe
i was being sworn in as uh chairman of
the united states commission on
international religious freedom i had
served uh
on the commission and was elected
chairman
so i was being sworn in uh as chairman
by chief justice john roberts at the at
the supreme court
so i asked brother cornell if uh if he
uh would do me the honor of holding the
bible for me not just any bible uh well
yes that's true we uh we uh we got uh
the wonderful people
at the uh
uh upstate new york at the um
uh
where is that it's somewhere in upstate
and around syracuse is that somewhere up
there yeah
uh
but this bible is a special bible it was
uh harriet harriet tubman's bible it was
the harriet tubman house that's what
they had
yes yes so the wonderful people there
gave us the the bible on loan great big
beautiful bible
i can imagine what that must have cost a
poor woman in harriet tubman's time an
ex-slave with no money uh to to purchase
that bible tells you something about her
faith absolutely and how she must have
treasured that bible but in any event
they they uh they gave us the bible on
loan for cornell to hold when i was
being sworn in in chief justice
roberts's chambers by the chief justice
well as we were walking up the
steps in front of the supreme court to
go into the building i'm walking with
brother cornell
and as we walk past a couple of police
officers security police i see one of
them catch cornell's eye
and the two of them cornell and the
officer stare at each other for a moment
then give each other a little head nod
and uh and we continue walking in and i
turned to brother cornell and i said
well what was that all about and he said
well brother robbie um
this is the first time i've ever been to
the supreme court when i wasn't here to
get arrested and that's the officer who
arrested me yeah
we went to jail i think for critique of
wall street or something like that chief
justice roberts was so gracious
absolutely your beloved parents
that was a magnificent magnificent
moment
absolutely right there is a new 25th
edition out of your best-selling book
race matters and in the new introduction
to that book cornell west you write
we live in one of the darkest moments in
american history a bleak time of
spiritual blackout and imperial meltdown
yeah yeah by spiritual blackout i mean
the relative eclipse of integrity
honesty and decency
i mean that we have normalized mendacity
which is to say we've made lies a normal
way of life and we've naturalized
criminality which is to say we've made
crimes
look as if
they are natural it could be drone
strikes it could be wall street elites
engaged in predatory lending a market
manipulation none of them go to jail it
could be so many different ways in which
a few people's
is violated and what we need is i call
for prophetic fight back
because in a moment of spiritual
blackout it's not just a political issue
it's a moral and a spiritual issue as
well and it's only by example we need
young people to say look he's a
conservative brother progressive brother
still have love still have respect
willing to fight willing to disagree not
in abstract by example
they want to see sermons they don't want
to just hear them
why because the
right now the dominant soul craft in the
american empire is a neoliberal soul
craft smartness smartness smartness it's
like how many times do you you hear the
word on television obvious obvious
obvious this is obviously obviously this
obviously that see that's
that's that's a word for the in in-crowd
to show that they're part of the smart
crowd
with brother robbie and i you see we
don't believe in smartness in this
isolation we believe in wisdom at its
deepest level
and smartness is tied to richness
there's no accident that donald trump
believes he's really the smartest in the
room and the richest in the room that's
just a sign of his spiritual vicuity and
emptiness but he's a sign and symptom of
a society that is idolized smartness and
richness and we want to talk about bombs
i mean what does
barack obama dropped
2672 bombs his last year he got the
nobel priest prize something like five
times as many drone strikes with
george bush got 45 bushels drone strikes
he got a 506 but he wins a nobel peace
prize so that what happens is this
spectacle can hide and conceal what real
substance is when it comes to morality
and spirituality and this is where it
breaks through ideology it's not just
right wing left wing center it's moral
and spiritual substance it's always
deeper than any political ideology you
see
and so what i'm trying to say in this in
this introduction is we are in
catastrophic times ecological
catastrophe nuclear catastrophe moral
catastrophe of just
survival of the slickest and the
smartest but then there's also economic
catastrophe grotesque wealth inequality
the top three individuals in america
have wealth equivalent to the bottom 160
million three brothers have wealth
equivalent to
50 of our fellow citizens
this is grotesque this looks like the
louis the 14th
times and so forth you see and now of
course we've got a tax bill now
well to do
off
tightening the benefits for the poor you
say wait a minute as christians we said
what you do to the least of these you do
unto us
the orphan the widow the fatherless the
motherless the poor the immigrant
the muslim the jew the black the
indigenous people the gay lesbian and so
forth and so on that's a moral and
spiritual orientation and so that book
is very much about where are we 25 years
after i wrote the book in 93 in times of
bleaker times of bleak or spiritually
immoral
i agree with the basic thrust of it now
cornell and i disagree about things like
markets whether
inequality in itself is a bad thing
economic inequality is a bad thing
i think our problem is not the market
economy i believe in the market economy
i think the market economy has lifted
millions of people out of poverty my uh
critique is that we have traded in a
true market economy for a kind of crony
capitalism
where uh big and powerful firms
can use government can use big
government absolutely to regulate
competitors uh off the off the field uh
big firms can afford
afford the price of regulation and
sometimes welcome it because they know
that small and upstart competitors
cannot welcome it when it comes to
economic equality i do not mind
inequality and i think in any just
system there will be inequal economic
inequality
i don't have as a goal
economic
equality i have as a goal equality and
dignity the equality of the declaration
of independence when it says that all
men are created equal we're all of equal
worth
but i've chosen a career as an academic
i know that's not a high paying a
particularly high paying field i could
have
gone to law school i would have made a
lot more money i could have gone to
business school and made a lot more
money than uh than that because
generally lawyers work for people who
make more money than they uh that's
coming from those schools yeah coming
from those schools yeah so
i don't have any uh problem with uh as
long as it's fair uh i don't have any
problem with people having even a lot
more money than other people my worry is
not for equality of economic equality my
worry is for opportunity my big worry
about our society is we are losing and
have to a considerable extent lost
the prospects for upward mobility for an
awful lot of our fellow citizens i grew
up in west virginia in central
appalachia uh i i remain close to people
there my entire family is still back
there my parents are there my brothers
are there
all of my family my my high school
friends so many of my friends and
relatives are there this was donald
trump country
now why
because they are feeling
the effects
of being neglected of being left behind
economically culturally they feel
without
uh uh bigotry or prejudice
but certainly on the basis of uh their
own experience as if there is a cultural
elite a wealthy powerful cultural elite
that has only its own interests in mind
not the interests of working people in
places like central appalachia
and who have nothing but contempt for
the values of people in central
appalachia those were trump
voters so i'm not one of these guys who
condemns trump voters i'm not a fan of
donald trump i wasn't from the beginning
and
i'll give him credit for some good
things he's done but i'll still
criticize him for some bad things that
he's done but i think that it's a
mistake
to imagine
that those supporters of donald donald
trump are just racists and bigots and
and horrible people
they had legitimate grievances which no
one in either party the establishment of
neither party responded to
and donald trump reached out
to them
whether they were wise
to look to him as their tribune that's
another we can debate that i have
debated that with my relatives and
friends uh in in in west virginia but he
noticed that those people were forgotten
were left behind were looked down on
were held in contempt war was waged on
their economy
and he benefited well cornell west
you do you agree with what he's saying
about the trump voters well i mean the
trump voters they're a diverse lot
they've got a slice of them who are in
fact xenophobic and racist and sexist
and misogynist and homophobic but that
doesn't exhaust the whole group brother
robbie acknowledges there's a racist
slice of trump voters you acknowledge
the racist slice of
these arrows that you see sticking out
of me they come from the alt-right
i'm considered the great city they're
one of the great satanists and a whole
host of other things right but there's
there's also a slice of trump voters who
had voted for bernie and had voted for
obama
so that you got to keep track of that
diversity of them you never want to
downplay
the role of the vicious legacy of white
supremacy in the country there's no
doubt about that but precisely because
it's so vicious you can't allow it to be
the only thing you see i mean you get
this out of brother coach and some of
the other younger black intellectuals
these days where all you can see is
white supremacy white supremacy is
always linked to something
else
it's a link to predatory capitalism it's
linked to slavery it's linked to jim
crow it's linked to patriarchy it's
linked to homophobia it's linked to
transphobia it's also linked to empire
you can have black and white soldiers
come together and go to the philippines
and treat the philippines like they
cockroaches the name of america
because you're you've got an empire at
that point so you have to be very honest
in telling the truth so brother brother
robbie and i say look we look at trump
voters let's tell the truth of who they
are they are a heterogeneous lot
many of them were suffering under
neo-liberal policies under barack obama
the top one percent got 95 of the income
growth i find that to be morally protest
now i don't agree for wholesale economic
equality
but i want to floor i want to focus on
poverty i want to focus on poor
people and we agree with that oh no we
agree with that because he's a
consultant i'm not worried about who's
deeply concerned about trying to ensure
that poverty is attacked he's been
trying to do it in conservative circles
i've tried to do it with barack obama
and the others the democratic party has
had no major concern about poor people
they've been tied to wall street and
tied to upward mobility for the
professional middle classes when it
comes to working people who are poor or
poor people not working at all they've
had very little to say other than some
movement on health care but that's a
market-driven healthcare program coming
out of the heritage foundation
established by milt romney mitt romney
you know mormon brother
salute him but he's not known for being
on the cutting edge of fighting against
poverty but he's somebody who in the
republican party did some very decent
things in regard to health care that's
where that health care program comes
from and we only be very honest about
that let us try to tell the truth about
both of our parties
deeply narrow when it comes to these
issues of poverty jack kemp and the
others putting pressure on the
republican party the legacy of martin
king putting pressure on the democratic
party and so but i think the other side
of this thing which we've really about
to have to be honest about is the
market-driven corporate media that made
donald trump the center of entertainment
where they made big big big big money
one of the ceos made it very clear
donald trump is bad for the country good
for us why is it good for you revenues
ratings they followed every speech every
twitter my dear brother bernie sanders
got like 20 seconds for every 30 minutes
that donald trump got why not have equal
treatment no it's market driven even in
the media thank god for c-span
can you imagine what the quality of
public dialogue would be in this country
without c-span because if it depends
just on corporate media
oh my god fox news
msnbc
it's propaganda machines
one's a conservative propaganda machine
the other neoliberal propaganda machine
now they're kind enough to invite us on
we have dialogue with him and so forth
but we know you know you're not gonna
get the most balanced view out of sean
hannity you're not gonna get the most
balanced view out of chris hayes
they've got their own agendas
and you can't just promote your agenda
you've got to be able to incident the
truth
you got to mention something bigger than
your own agenda that's how democracy is
you know this is this is
highly relevant in education as well
especially especially higher education
but really k-12 through higher education
uh
you got to tell the truth you have to
tell them please try to tell the truth
but yeah i mean too often
one extreme whitewashes american history
so you take out the unsavory and the
indigenous peoples
working people
labor movement the other side tells an
equally false history that this is the
whole story that the whole story of the
american experience is
slavery white supremacy imperialism and
so forth
leading many of our young people to
reject
the foundational principles of america
which are really what do make the
country great what's exceptional about
america
we're human beings like other human
beings we're made of flesh and blood
we're dust of the earth but also made in
the very image and likeness of god we're
human beings like other human beings
it's not
us as human beings who are exceptional
it's the principles on which the country
rests it's the principles on which we
were founded that it has taken a long
time for us to live up to and we still
don't live up to them fully and we
probably never will fully live up to
them because they're high aspirational
principles but they're captured in that
wonderful
we hear it so often that it becomes a
cliche but we really need to stop and
listen to those words we hold these
truths to be self-evident that all men
are created equal that they're endowed
by their creator with certain
unalienable rights and among these are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness a nation founded on that
principle has the potential
for greatness
and we need to communicate that
uh to our young people and we need to
tell the truth yes with the warts but
not imagining that the history is
nothing but rewards when martin luther
king appealed to the american people he
did not take a french revolutionary
attitude that we need to tear down
everything that came before it because
it's corrupt and evil and we need to
build something new that nobody else has
ever seen before no no no no
martin luther king
looked back
to the american founding
despite the fact that the man who wrote
the words i quoted was a slave holder
that did not stop king
from looking back to the american
founding and saying
the principle is right and good now
let's live up to the principle our
founders wrote a check let's cash the
check let's make good on the check
that's what we need to do we need to
call people back to our founding
principles and i want to get to your
reaction to that professor west in just
a minute but first i want to welcome our
viewers this is our monthly in-depth
program where we invite one author on to
talk about his or her body of work this
month it's a unique situation we have
professors robert george and cornell
west who for years taught a class
together at princeton cornell west has
now returned to harvard
robert george remains at princeton
here are the numbers here's the way you
can interact with these two 202 is the
area code
748-8200 if you live in the east and
central time zones
202-748-8201 for those of you in the
mountain and pacific now if you can't
get through on the phone line still want
to make a comment several ways via
social media including twitter at book
tv
on our facebook page you'll see a video
of these two together you can make a
comment right under there facebook.com
slash book tv instagram book tv and
finally email book tv at cspan.org
very quickly we want to just show you a
few of the books that these two have
written beginning with cornell west new
25th edition out brand new of his best
seller race matters that was originally
published in 1993
democracy matters came out in 2004
brother west his autobiography
came out in 2009 and his most recent
book is black prophetic fire 2014.
now robert george a couple of his books
making men moral
1995 the clash of orthodoxies 2001
conscience and its enemies 2013
and conjugal union is one of his most
recent books what marriage is
and why it matters we'll begin taking
those phone calls in just a minute
professor west your reaction to what
robert george was saying just a minute
ago no i think that brother robbie's
commitment to telling the truth and the
condition of truth is always to allow
suffering to speak so if we tell the
truth about him i was looking at a book
the other day by the great barnard
devoto called the course of empires
published in the 1950s and he makes the
point of course the united states was a
settler colonial enterprise like canada
like new zealand like australia like
liberia like israel there's a whole host
of efforts of people who are escaping
ugly conditions to arrive on a land
and there's some other people there
and you have to decide do you coexist do
you dominate do you subordinate do you
engage in genocidal
assault or whatever that the united
states what is distinctive about the
united states as a settler colonial
society was it was a successful
revolutionary
effort to overthrow the empire from
which it came the fight against george
iii
with the grand ideals that brother
robbie was talking about and those
ideals have universal implications but
they still have these very ugly
realities you then have slavery you then
have white men who can't vote who don't
have property you have women in
patriarchal households you got gay
brothers and lesbians and trans and
others who are marginalized and yet by
appealing to those ideals
in the context of the u.s
social experiment we've been able to
make some significant progress how do
you stay in contact with the humanity of
indigenous peoples black peoples women
gays lesbian working people
mexicans and so forth and so on at the
same time we've got a long way to go no
doubt about that but it's a matter of
just trying to tell the truth so we
understand what are the impediments what
are the major obstacles and i think one
of the things that brother avi and i we
we wrestle with because he he defends
the market economy in the right form
he's not for crony capitalism he's not
for any kind of uh reckless
laissez-faire capitalism he understands
there's need for regulations i mean is
that is that fair absolutely
fundamentally for regulation and and i
believe that in market economies in the
history of this nation we've resulted in
monopolies and oligopolies
the robber barons of the 1890s you see
the financial elites today who have a
disproportionate amount of power and
influence with very little democratic
accountability so that the market
economy i can agree with to the degree
to which it's got these thick
regulations that doesn't allow for
ways in which
persons are thoroughly unaccountable and
that has nothing to do with trashing
them i mean we got brother harlan crowe
who was our dear brother i was just with
him this week what they had to debate
with brother alan dershowitz on the
palestinian question of bds now harlan
crowe is one of the finest human beings
you ever meet
there's just no doubt about that there's
no doubt about that so we're not talking
about the character of a particular
individual there's some other friends of
his who have much less moral care than
he does
be they rich middle class or whatever
but it's the structure that we're
talking about because oligopolies and
monopolies do not lend themselves to
democratic accountability to sustain
democracy but dr west didn't you just
kind of
put everybody in a tribe and and talk
about some of the isms
that
you both decried a little bit earlier is
that a fair statement when we talk about
class we're really talking about the
ways in which various forms of power are
used and deployed you still can keep
track of their humanity as individuals
and there for example there are certain
individuals who are poor
who choose immoral ways of living in the
world
there's middle class people
who choose immoral ways there's
well-to-do people who choose immoral
ways so we're talking about character
what kinds of choices people make but
the structures that are in place
are not reducible just to their
character you see structures have to be
confronted as structures
so you can have the most benevolent
class of slave holders in the world and
slavery is still evil
because the structure of slavery is evil
and we understand slavery to be as a
structure
evil you see and so in that sense we
don't want to reduce structures to
individual characters characters can
choose and those choices have more
weight they have ethical
resonance there's no doubt about that
but it's a matter of keeping track of
the structures i think part of the uh
the fascinating kind of conversation
brother robbie and i have is trying to
deal with this complex dialectical
interplay between structures and
individual structures and persons as it
were when he talks about making human
beings moral
and if you worked on a slaveholder to
become more moral without an indictment
of slavery
is still not enough
you'd agree with that oh yeah i agree
absolutely so
i have a few points to make sure
responsible
uh
first is i think the last thing we want
and we might disagree about this but the
last thing we want is the socialization
the government control and ownership of
the means of production
i see that as the high road to tyranny
so that's why i reject the socialist
because my kind of democratic socialism
has a crucial role for private sector
well that seems to be very critical the
second i think i agree with that while i
do believe that uh markets need to be
regulated there should be some things
that aren't for sale uh yes i agree and
there is a place for market values which
is in the market there's a there's a
place for non-market values and you
don't want market values invading
non-market familial for example
relationships
when it comes to regulation this is a
very tricky area
i want to minimize regulation i think
the only regulations we should have are
regulations that are necessary but there
are many regulations that are necessary
if we over regulate we defeat our very
purpose because what we do is we empower
large enterprises who can use regulatory
obstacles to prevent smaller competitors
from getting into the competition so you
need wise regulation and wise regulation
will let the market operate to the
extent that the market can operate
fairly and without
exploitation and without
undermining institutions like the family
that are not built on
market
principles i think when we do that
then we do liberate the market to
benefit especially
less well-off people that's what creates
the um social mobility the economic
opportunity that allows people
to rise which of course
is the is the greatest
aspect of the american story when you
think about it how many people have come
from other lands as immigrants to this
country with nothing shirt on their
backs
and have become wealthy
i'd also want to point out there's just
nothing wrong with being rich in itself
depending as long as you became rich you
can't steal somebody else's land steal
that money steal their resources but
think of how many people
in this country
are the children or grandchildren or
perhaps themselves immigrants who did
really come with nothing or very little
and through hard work initiative
willingness to take risks have acquired
great wealth and then think of how many
of them have become
generous benefactors to every worthy
cause
to the cause of justice to the cause of
human health to the cause of education
institutionalization princeton and
harvard are profoundly dependent on the
generosity
but philanthropy is not justice though
that it's that it is
that means that there are power centers
outside of the control of government and
that's important and i think that's bad
because we've got to be
anti-authoritarian across the board but
the problem is that if for example we
agree
that it's crony capitalism it's
predatory capitalism and then there's no
regulation oh that then the weak and the
vulnerable are really crushed
exactly right and the way to beat that
fundamentally is to empower the
competitors it's to make the market work
it's not to do away with the market it's
not to undermine the market it's to
empower competitors to compete well see
i would say more than that we empower
the competitors and here we with joseph
sean peter and the others the crucial
role of entrepreneurs not just
monopolies and oligopolies but those new
upstarts trying to gain a foothold in
the market but the other crucial
countervailing force is organized labor
even given this possibility of
corruption if workers have no say in
their workplace then for the most part
given the profit driven orientation of
the elites they're not going to be
treated right we've seen this in your
beloved west virginia if it wasn't for
those those unions and the mines they
would be crushing those precious
brothers of all kinds like i don't know
and uh and and i i think that's a very
legitimate point but it's the the
corruption of labour
cuts across
color gender sexual orientation nation
that's who we are as a species so we
have to have some kind of uh this uh
this uh
this fall i uh have just finished uh
teaching uh seminar at harvard law
school with a colleague up there
wonderful scholar named adrian vermeuel
where we looked at uh uh law in light of
the teaching of the modern popes going
back to leo the 13th the traditional the
tradition of what's called catholic
social thought and one of the things
that struck me in reading through these
documents again from rarom navaram in
1891 all the way up through the
encyclical sentesama sanus on the 100th
anniversary of ram navaram which was by
pope john paul the second is that the
popes are trying to find a way to avoid
the errors on the one side of socialism
and government control of the means of
production and the sk and the and the
destruction of liberty that comes in the
wake of that that's on the one side but
then on the other side
uh the kind of capitalism that creates
plutocracy absolutely uh that where
where people can use wealth
to squeeze out competitors to get
control of an economic situation so that
they can engage in exploitation one of
the things that the pope's
urge
is trying to find ways for workers to
participate not only in the management
of businesses where their voices are
heard which will benefit businesses as
well as workers themselves but also find
ways that workers can have equity
participation especially in larger firms
and i think that is a very good
direction to try to go in when workers
are part owners of firms that can only
benefit the firms and it certainly
benefits the uh the workers i'd much
rather see us move in that direction
than government control than a socialist
director this is where we learn from our
scandinavian scandinavian brothers and
sisters
norway
the opposite in the great legacy that
goes with doorways james finland and
others where you actually got workers on
the board
so when fundamental decisions are made
regarding the destiny of the enterprise
the workers voices have some weight they
have some substance
michael harrington and the others tried
to push that in the 1980s
and it didn't didn't go too far but i
think right now we're living in a moment
in which there is a crony capitalism at
work there is an oligopoly and a
monopoly that's running things but it's
shifted it's no longer industrial based
it's bank
it's in the banking and technology it's
in technology and banking google
facebook firms firms like this and and
then wall street
connection to silicon valley it's a very
intimate relation they have to go right
here i'm sorry yeah well i'm just
thinking of of the um
the the civil liberties problems that
are created when you have essentially a
kind of
new public square
in the form of platforms like
facebook
where people
should be able to interact freely but
it's a private for-profit business which
is fine i have no problem with that
uh and yet if facebook can exercise
a lot of control over what is said if it
can engage in effect in censorship then
how far have we
really respected civil liberties a
monopoly or oligopoly has now placed
itself in the position functionally of
government exercising uh uh censorship
and i know that there are a lot of uh
conservatives who are now very concerned
very worried
about cases in which the conservative
point of view has been censored from
places like facebook and it's probably
happening to people with other
perspectives as well i of course i'm
much more likely to hear it from
conservatives but that seems to be a
genuine worry if you've got a case of
monopoly or oligopoly now if you have a
truly competitive marketplace things
will take care of themselves the
business will gravitate uh to where uh
the free flow of information can uh can
occur but we don't have that with firms
like google and facebook and so forth
you have monopoly and oligopoly now and
i think that's going to be a challenge
for uh
i guess my dear brothers glenn ford in
the other black agenda reports saying
that look it's almost
it's nearly impossible for radical
voices
to have a deep
rooted anchorage
when it comes to the public square
which is very much driven by these
private companies you see
and that's going to be a problem why
because i mean one of the fundamental
questions this is a great question
lorraine hansenberry one of the finest
artists 20th century she's how do you
bequeath to the younger generation
the best visions
examples of courage individual and
collective to the younger generation
because without those milestones in the
past
without us connecting to those
milestones in the past all they have to
go on is the chaos of the present
and the present is all about money
spectacle status
that's the neoliberal soul craft
and i say neo-liberal because it's not
just political it's spiritual it's moral
and it tells young people the ending aim
of life is to be successful in terms of
material wealth
power and military might it says very
little about greatness in terms of the
quality of their spirits and the quality
of their moral character you see and
that is
the death knell
of any civilization
because no civilization can survive if
it loses sight of the rich examples of
those who came before who bequeathed
them a moral and spiritual
spiritual heritage not just a
great example of success when it comes
to money status and power can i say word
about this because this is a point on
which i fundamentally agree with cornell
let me put it this way
we've got a wonderful form of government
our constitutional
system the madisonian system
has shown that you can make a republic
work that was an open question in 1776
in 1789 and 1791 whether republican
government could work because it had
been tried in many places before in the
ancient world in the medieval and
renaissance worlds uh and
failed and failed
uh we've got a wonderful system of
republican government we've got a
wonderful constitutional system i i i'd
like us to be more faithful to it i
think we've often deviated when we we
shouldn't have large deviations with
indigenous peoples and slavery and so
forth
we've got a great we've got a great
system i think the market system is a
good system
if if we can push out the crony
capitalism and really get a market to
work as a competitive
thing so that
so that we get the benefits of
better goods and services at lower
prices the market does its work of
improving quality and reducing cost
that's a great thing
but in the long run
you cannot sustain either republican
government
or the market economy which are great
benefits to our people
if you do not have a moral foundation
and that moral foundation doesn't just
happen
that spiritual formation that moral
formation
that
sound understanding of what matters in
life what it means to be a human being
what our obligations to others are the
market won't produce that for you nor
will the system of government produce
that for you if it's going to be
produced for you it will be by the
family
and the institutions of civil society of
religion and neighborhood and civic
association that assist the family in
its role as the basic transmitter of
values of character to each new
generation
and we need to protect
those institutions of civil society
because beginning with the family they
really are the the primordial department
of health education and welfare they do
more than just diaper the kids and get
them fed and off to school and and so
forth they form them as the kinds of
human beings they will be that's what i
mean by being transmitters of of values
so look the economy
the market system and our republican
form of government both depend on
something that neither can produce
and that is reasonably virtuous decent
honorable citizens
who can be good
citizens of the republic who can be good
participants in the in the market
they can't produce them they rely on
something else
to do that like an irene and clifton
west oh that's true
that's very absolutely very much so when
you talk about mom and dad we can talk
about his parents talking about your
parents you're talking about
persons who have been shaped
by what the isaac brothers call a
caravan of love
it's a love of truth the love of justice
the love of neighbor and as christians
we love our enemies but you don't try
that on your own in a whole lot of fig
grace for that and a love of the holy
for those who are religious granted i
think there's a whole host of atheistic
and agnostic brothers and sisters who
have great spirituality and moral
character sometimes even more than than
we christians so i don't believe that
love of holy is a prerequisite for being
a person of integrity i know people of
great integrity who don't believe in god
but as a christian myself
i know that i i cannot preserve my
sanity
without viewing myself as part of a
great tradition of a hated people who
taught the world much of how to love
and when you look at the history of the
american republic for example what would
have happened to the united states if
instead of frederick douglass and
harriet tubman you had black versions of
the klan
what would happen to america if in the
1960s you didn't have monister king
junior fannie lou hamer but you had a
black version of the clan so when they
killed the four girls in birmingham your
response is to kill for white girls on
the vanilla side of town it was
spiritual and moral character of black
people
that constituted the leaven for the
american democratic loaf it would have
been a civil war every generation if you
had these absolutely right terrorist
terrors of black people if we had black
isis or black versions of isis let's say
in america there'd be no american
democracy because you can't keep track
of all of us but no it was a moral
spiritual tradition that produced irene
cliff my brother cliff my sister cynthia
cheryl lord ronnie when i was a little
and a gangster but i always tell i was a
gangster before i met jesus and now i'm
a gangster with
i'm a redeemed center with gangster
proclivity but i still got gangster
proclivities and i need people to keep
me in place you know what i mean
right-wing brothers left-wing brother
whatever it is my loved ones and what
have you but the important thing is
robbie's point
is the lynchpin
if you lose that moral and spiritual
heritage you have a war all against all
and thrasymachus triumphs over socrates
might makes right you impose coercion
tremendous violence as opposed to a love
a justice a dialogue a democracy
or an attempt of some kind of civilized
society and we're we're reaching the
point where we're running out of gas
we're running out of spiritual and moral
gas in the united states in the 40s and
50s and 60s it was not a foregone
conclusion
uh that uh the the way forward uh that
uh uh african-americans would adopt
would be the peaceful one of martin
luther
king it was elijah muhammad that was the
early malcolm x before his own uh
conversion to uh an orthodox form of
islam uh and many others who were
pointing in
in another direction a more radical
violence just had the soldiers coming
back fighting a thug called hitler
racism then you come back to racist
america jim crow and when we know the
story in terms of the double victory
that hey philip randolph was calling
racism in europe racism in america we
crushed the thugs in europe thank god
with the help of black and white
soldiers together and to help the soviet
army
we come back home these black soldiers
treated like second-class citizens all
of in uniform but what made that
possible i want to suggest what made it
possible for african americans to opt
for the path of martin luther king
was the black church
that culture that's true that produced
irene and clifton west that's true
was sustained by the black church over
all those decades and decades and
centuries of slavery and jim crow
and
depression and i think you know people
these days forget that they forget the
role that the black church played
in sustaining
uh african americans and making it
possible for us to make the progress
that we have made and as much credit as
martin luther king deserves it's not
just martin luther king it's not
something that happened starting in 1961
or 1959 or 1965
this was sustained over generations
in black nowadays just one footnote that
happened this is where we get to the
music
because i think the black musical
tradition is one of the if not the
greatest
tradition in the modern world of
moral and spiritual fortitude and by
fortitude i mean diffusion of courage
and magnanimity courage and greatness of
character because courage could be i
said you can have a nazi soldier who's
courageous and still a gangster but when
you have courage and greatness of
character so that the music that came
out of the black church so that the ray
charles and the aretha franklins and the
marvin gayes and the dramatics and the
whispers and the maintenance ingredients
they were no longer always christians
but the music that they were producing
was still shot through was a love ethic
that kept track of the humanity of
others so like james baldwin who leads
the church but the love ethic never
leaves him
and the black music has played a
fundamental role in humanizing our
relations with each other much of it
rooted in the black church but not
always tied to the dogma of
the black church i mean john cole strain
love supreme doesn't fit into christian
dogma
but it sure fits into christian love
and that has played a crucial role in
allowing vanilla brothers and sisters to
say lo and behold
these people have an intelligence at the
creativity imagination and a genius that
speaks to my soul so white supremacy
might be a lie
even though it's alive it might be a lie
now you hear this brother play the
guitar
and he plays serious guitar oh
probably brother robert can play some
guitar very much so he understands the
role of music
that flows from the church
but also flows outside of the church but
that love ethic is still informing that
you get in bruce springsteen he's a
blues vanilla brother to the core he's
connected to the black church to the
degree to which the black music that is
rooted in what he does coming from the
white side of town and doing it in his
own way fascinating relation to the
spiritual stuff that we need in order to
go forward in your autobiography brother
west you refer to yourself frequently as
a bluesman oh absolutely what does that
mean but i'm first and foremost a blues
man a blues person is somebody whose
personal narrative is shot through with
catastrophe but engages in lyrical
expression of that catastrophe and it
doesn't allow the hatred to have the
last world
that's what blues is bb king says nobody
loves me but my mom and she might be
driving too
that's a catastrophe at the highest
level
that's like antigones and sophocles play
but how does he respond to catastrophe
with a smile with style with compassion
with his soul emptying himself to
connect to other people's soul so even
when he's playing his guitar with
lucille that's the name of his guitar
right he's connecting on a human level
to his audience whatever color they are
but he's coming out of gut bucket jim
crow mississippi genius saying this love
ethic will not be stopped mediated with
this guitar you see and you can hear
robert johnson here betsy smith that
tradition all through his music and he's
not the only one but we can just begin
with the king of bb when you can talk
about bessie smith from our rainy you
could talk about a
charlie parker you could talk about
stevie wonder whoever
and the role of music i mean i believe
that the artists are the vanguard of the
species and that the musicians are the
vanguard of the artist but when your
music gets commodified
when your music gets marketized it no
longer has moral and spiritual substance
like so much music today you know that
the spiritual crisis is intensifying all
right we've spent an hour talking we're
going to get our callers involved but is
this it all similar to what your classes
were like
yeah
that's right i mean the difference is we
usually have a text we have augustus
confessions we got played all the
republic we got stopped he's
anticipating the boys yeah that's true
you referred to the black people
that's just a character in uh plato's
republic
so we have texts that we're bouncing off
right now we have each other
and yourself thank god but but in a
classroom you know we've got to deal
with subject matter with the textbook
line how much would this have cost to
attend this class
gosh princeton and harvard i think the
uh i think that the tuition and fees now
are well over sixty thousand dollars am
i right now of course they're very
because of generous donors to these
universities and the big endowments that
they've been able to build which is a
big issue now about whether those
endowments should be taxed
but because of that there are very
generous financial aid
packages so large percentages of our
students i believe now we're well over a
majority uh certainly at princeton i
believe this is true at harvard
are receiving some financial aid and
many many of them are receiving
large financial aid packages in uh i
think a fair number of cases
it ends up being cheaper for a student
to go to harvard or princeton than it
would be to go to his home state
university or one of his home state
universities because of the generous
financial aid that's uh that's available
the problem of course is that there are
a limited number of spaces at these
universities
and the competition for one of those
spaces is extremely uh intense so places
like princeton and harvard are only
admitting
5.16
of the of the students
who apply absolutely as
notable professors on these campuses are
you
encouraged to fundraise
not really no no generally not i began
i began becoming a fundraiser and i am
one now i do a lot of fundraising now
when princeton
authorized me to found a program called
the james madison program in american
ideals and institutions that was back in
in 2000 so we're in the 17th year
and this is a program brother cornell
was a fellow of our program a year
before year before last
this
this center this program builds on
princeton's historic strength in areas
like political philosophy constitutional
law
american history to try to enrich our
students uh understandings of american
ideals and institutions and the broader
civilizational
structures
that made possible uh the american
founding now uh
because uh
when i founded the
madison program the university made
clear that while they would assist with
fundraising we would not be given an
annual allocation of money from the
university's central account
uh i
have to raise the money each year for
the uh the program and we're now up to
uh over a two million dollar annual
budget so i have to i have to be out
there raising the money
our development office is very helpful
at princeton i'm very grateful to them
for helping me we have uh
some generous alumni who support us we
have foundations uh who support us uh so
because of that particular
unusual circumstance for me
i have become a fundraiser but princeton
didn't put any pressure on me to do that
i wanted to do something i wanted to do
something new
i wanted to introduce as a model i hope
for other universities uh a program that
that would enrich our students
understanding of basic american
constitutional and moral uh principles
and that ended up making me a fundraiser
i've met a lot of wonderful people
this way it's a burden i have to tell
you it's a burden but it's a fundraiser
your charming things help facilitate
warm relationships
and i've been very blessed to be
be a fellow now again just for the
audience
he's got fellows who
don't have economic support i was part
of the fellow because i was teaching in
the freshman seminar and he was open
enough to be able to jointly support
that seminar
but in terms because you've got some
fellows who receive financial that
support and so forth you've got some
fellows who are just glad to beat it and
i'm glad to be there because i uh i'm
just in there for the dialogue so we
contributed the course that cornell
taught so the madison program funded in
princeton university the course that it
was a freshman the freshman seminar
itself that was taught at the university
itself but you can see you see i am not
the ideal person to go out and raise
money
for an elite institution
because i love to be part of the
conversation but a lot of times my
critiques can be so intense that they
say to themselves we're not really sure
that this public face is the most
effective
in terms of being able to raise money
now sometimes they do if they have a
broad perspective if they're committed
to a robust uninhibited conversation
then i think we might be able to get
some contributors but a lot of time to
say well
i i think a lot of people certainly it's
pretty radical to be raising money for
well to do i mean when i was on the
guggenheim one of the conditions i had
was that they supported the learning
through the arts program and went
marcellus and myself had to make sure
that poor children throughout harlem and
other places had access to instruments
so you come into these big institutions
concerned about the weak and the
vulnerable and ensure that these
institutions are attending to what
they're about
and so in that sense
i wouldn't mind but i think generally
speaking they probably hold off on me
though it's a very interesting
experience that i've had because when it
comes even to my fundraising for the
madison program at princeton
uh
our donors
almost universally
uh including our conservative donors and
many of our donors are themselves
politically conservative
have
counted it very much in favor of the
program that cornell and i do the work
that
we do together i got not a single
complaint from a donor or anybody else
about our sponsoring cornell's course
last year and making him a family and
that was on uh martin king and abraham
joshua yesterday that's a great
prophetic figure that's true and and the
work that cornell and i do both at
princeton around the country together uh
i find that supporters of the madison
program are just enthusiastic about that
this is what they want to see they want
to see the civil but robust engagement
of ideas they want to see people working
together across all sorts of different
lines yeah but we'd have to be together
i think if i'm not sure they even invite
me all by myself
and it's understandable you know because
the left way not inviting you by
yourself yeah we uh we had an experience
last year when we spoke at the american
enterprise institute yeah yeah together
it was wonderful and as we were walking
out brother cornell uh and we were
treated so graciously and so wonderful
authors and brother arthur brooks yes uh
and uh as we were walking out cornell
said to me brother robbie i have to say
i'm not sure that a a progressive think
tank would have treated you as well as i
have been treated here now i hope that's
not true but i don't know we haven't
tested it but i do wonder i do wonder
that's very true but when you have money
and power and privilege it might be
easier to treat somebody nice as opposed
to folk who basically are pushed against
the wall right now the left is so weak
you know was so feeble right i i don't
see it that way i i see it the opposite
way
the liberals the liberals are powerful
but not the left you mean the uh yeah
you see the liberal we don't want to
confuse liberals on the left now oh not
at all these liberals are tied to wall
street and imperial expansion and drone
strikes and surveillance and national
security state in ways that we had to be
very critical of
gentlemen we're going to get our callers
involved they're on hold we're going to
begin with a call from a woman named e
in suitland maryland e you are on with
cornell west and robert george go ahead
we're listening
i would like to call this a true
spiritual serendipity i just came out of
prayer about an hour ago and everything
seems to fit the only question i'd like
for you to focus on is what do you think
of disavowing
uh being in the republican and or
democratic parties and file as
independent with this more spiritual
truly spiritual stance
and i do have we're gonna let
you know what we're going to leave it
there and we're going to let cornell
west answer
robert george if you'd flip the switch
on your box that should uh turn on your
audio not that one don't turn that one
and garrett will come in and take care
of that in just a minute so cornell west
if you want to answer that caller we'll
we'll figure that out uh
professor george go ahead well one i
just want to thank you for your own
spirit in terms of
resonating with what we're trying to
convey
but as we know i mean spirit can go in
so many different directions and i'm
just concerned that when we talk about
spirituality that is tied very much
to social justice for the most
vulnerable in our society no matter who
they are vulnerable in the world and
therefore when it comes to choosing
which particular political party i think
we ought to look at the world through
the lens of the most vulnerable as a
christian for me that's what it means to
look at the world through the lens of
the cross
for amos when he talked about looking at
his own society through the lens of
those who were suffering
and that could easily lead toward
you being an independent
very much so i think that could that
could be a sign of a certain kind of
integrity because i think both of our
political parties are just shot through
with
levels of myopia and cowardice and tied
to big money that is so sad and so
disempowering so i think we need more
independence but again the choice is up
to you i don't believe in dictating
anybody's choices and next up is ron in
babylon new york ron good afternoon we
are listening to you please go ahead
yeah i respect the values of love and
caring for others
uh and the uh liberation of self
and and the concern for others so i
think that's something that i really
respect and i think both you gentlemen
uh
have talked about and uh our champions
of the question that i have
is you also have the principles of
our country and belief in our country
and the way the country was set up and
part of that is the congress
and part of that congress
is
the the actual
uh compromise of the congress say the
current tax bill there's some good
things and some bad things in that tax
bill
how does that deal with the ideal of
morality and love when indeed
the road that we're on is an incremental
incremental road and a growth road and
compromise sometimes has some bad
elements in it so i have a question in
that area
thank you very much robert george the
only part of that you missed was her
kind comments about this discussion but
then she went on to talk about the tax
bill cornell west if you'd like to start
well no i think brother robinson jump in
on that you're sure no i think the tax
bill is colossal failure when it comes
to issues of morality and spirituality
tied to the vulnerable there's no doubt
about it you start slashing
corporate rates for tax
corporate corporations are able to hire
these very very smart lawyers to create
loopholes already they got offshore tax
havens already and now you're going to
slice it with it from 39 they want to
take it all the way down to 20. i don't
believe that the conservative argument
often put forward not by all
conservatives but many that if you slash
the taxes of the rich that somehow
that's going to generate economic growth
that will have an uplift for the most
vulnerable i do not see evidence of that
uh and i hear it over and over again so
i do
resonate with what you said initially
about our concern about the vulnerable
if you look at our tax this particular
tax bill through the lens of the
vulnerable and impact on them it's a
colossal failure
my own view is that we did need to and
do need to cut corporate taxes to make
our own businesses more competitive
we have among if not the highest
corporate tax rates
in the world and that has adverse
consequences for american workers
this is a classic case of watching the
sausage being made watching watching
legislation is like watching sausage
being made and yes there are lots of
compromises that are made and some of
them are very unfortunate
i have a worry it was the worry that
caused
senator corker from tennessee to vote
against the bill uh in the senate which
is that we're further expanding uh the
deficit we're not dealing with uh
spending uh with spending uh issues
i i think
a lot of uh ordinary people get a small
tax cut
a lot of wealthy people get a much
larger uh tax cut taxes will go up for
some uh wealthy people not for
others it's going to be a complicated
situation but at the end of the day i
don't think what we will have is
fundamental change
i don't see this as a big breakthrough
and i don't see it as a big catastrophe
it'll shift a few things
around but it's not fundamental change
what i would like to see is a rethinking
of the whole system but that means
tackling something that nobody wants to
tackle and that is the spending side
also
and here i'm going to introduce
an issue that one almost never hears
about these days there's also the issue
on the monetary
side we have had artificially low
interest rates for a very very long time
perhaps an unprecedentedly large time
i'm not sure about that but it's
certainly in my lifetime
uh we've never had such a period of uh
of very very low interest rates and of
course that's the work of
of uh of of the fed there were winners
and losers as a uh as a result of that
and we don't pay nearly enough uh
attention to monetary policy and i think
there really should be a serious robust
debate about that but again it's it's
it's not happening so i i think what
we're getting in this tax bill at the
end of the day after all the sturm and
drang and all the dramatic speeches by
the senators on both sides and so forth
is not a lot of change just some
relatively minor uh rearrangements and
the reform that we need is not happening
and both sides agree still that for
every 53 dollars
53 cents out of a dollar
it goes to the military so that when it
comes to serious interrogation and
accountability of the military
industrial complex very little talk
coming out of either party
and that's tied to our adventurism
that's tied to our foreign policy that
oftentimes does not have financial
accountability to public interest well
i'm a person who believes in a strong
military as you know but but
a military has gotten
the same right rules of accountability
absolutely everybody else i mean too
often it's just easy to say i've
increased military spending vote for me
i've made our nation stronger vote and
that money is taken and they don't have
money for schools of quality and
jobs with a living wage and decent
housing and so forth yeah let's hear
from barbara in oak bluffs massachusetts
good afternoon barbara
hi thank you whoever said one in one
doesn't make three has never encountered
this particular road show here
absolutely thrilling
thrilling conversation
i learned that mit put their entire
curriculum online years ago and i would
like to ask these two to get this
freshman seminar filmed online for pbs
or
npr it could be radio it could be a
podcast just get it out here okay
um the the obvious power of this
partnership is so extraordinary and it's
almost like
a left brain right brain partnership
because um brother west is so warm and
brother other is so cool and yet
the words and the ideas are you know
where it's at
one more thing one more thing it's very
important that we use memes m-e-m-e-s um
intelligently now in this social media
age okay
and um i tuned in at 10 after 12 and i
heard the word soul craft and i'd never
heard that and obviously you know it's
an invention of brother west here i
think or both of them together
but for me
i
to me the better meme to focus on is
integrity okay because
integrity is
is a historical in other words it's not
connected to religion it doesn't have
that
you know i don't want a bad mouth soul
because of that magnificent thing that
you did on the music and all that it's
true but but for this younger generation
i'm 70 okay i'm a reformed jew i i'm an
intellectual but we have to understand
that we aren't going to be here much
longer and we have to figure out how to
communicate this moral integrity thing
to this next generation it's not their
fault they were born we're going to
leave it there and we're going to hear
from
brother west and brother robert brother
brother that's it i missed it already
well i want to thank our our caller for
that kind of that kind comment
um
my own uh
large undergraduate course one of my
large undergraduate courses which is a
course in civil liberties is going to
go online fairly soon we're going to do
the first online version of that
starting uh starting this spring so this
is an experiment uh for me i've been
looking at what some other scholars have
done including our friend michael sandel
who's done it at harvard with this
course on justice his wonderful course
on justice and done it very successfully
so i'm hoping to to make that work for
my civil liberties course but a seminar
is a different thing and it's a very
special thing cornell and i have
wrestled with uh the question of whether
we should make our seminar more public
for example we've had a lot of reporters
who've asked to sit in on the seminar
and do an article about it or do a clip
about it on a news cast or something
like that
and we have in the end always decided no
now why have we decided no
when someone is in there watching and
reporting or when you're online or when
you're doing it as an online course the
students know that they're on display
the beauty of a seminar
uh is that people
knowing that they're not on display are
willing to experiment with ideas to
speak their minds to try a thought out
even if it
uh might turn out that it's not going to
work and might even be embarrassing
so to try to preserve the intimacy
of the uh of the seminar to try to make
sure students do not feel as though
they're on display
in that format we've opted uh against
any
broader involvement of people
in the seminar trying to make it more
widely available it's a shame because
there's such magic in the seminar we
would love to
share it
but we just haven't been able to find a
way
to do that now we could shift to a
different format we could do a big
lecture course together
but i'll let the viewers in on a little
secret
you get two big mouth show-offs in a
classroom in a lecture context in front
of 6-800 students
you're gonna lose some of the magic that
you get
when is somebody given fourth no that's
true now roberto anger who's one of the
towering
figures
versus
critical theorists at harvard law where
brother robbie also teaches he and i
teach a course at the law school called
american democracy and we put each
lecture
on youtube and he's been doing this for
a long time but that's the case where
you have two persons who give lectures
very little exchange because by the time
we're done the class is over so you miss
that socratic element that dialogical
moment that's so very very important
that brother robbie and i just revel in
because we learn so much from each other
and we're empowered by each other and
the students are able to
feel that energy ricocheting off our
interaction but i love what my dear
sister said from oak bluff because
hopeless very special place that's what
martha's vineyard isn't it that's a very
special place yeah i think that's a
chocolate section of of martha's
vineyard well a lot of high quality
black folk
live and come to terms our jewish sister
here is uh in good company and they're
in good company too she writes in terms
of soul craft though when i talked about
the eclipse of integrity honesty decency
generosity she's absolutely right that
when we talk about soul crap as a fancy
term and i didn't make it up robert
didn't make it up this goes all the way
back to plato goes all the way back to
medieval social theorists and political
theorists all the way through our modern
time but the issue of integrity honesty
decency generosity courage fortitude
magnet magnanimity all these need to
just not be talked about
people have to see it exemplify
enact it
on the ground day by day grin by grin
touch by touch
laugh by laugh
movement by movement
uh our caller raises a very very
important uh uh question i'd like to
explore that sure um
could we jettison religion
uh or relegate it to the purely personal
sphere
and in our public discussions just talk
in terms of things like integrity
apart from religion and dismiss talk
about the soul
i've heard this suggestion before and i
know a lot of good people believe it i
cannot persuade myself that it is
correct
i think if we go down that route
what we will be doing basically is
spending down the capital of our great
religious traditions especially and of
course in our culture the jewish and
christian traditions spending down the
capital
without replenishing it
so yes i i agree with brother cornell
and i know from firsthand experience
that one need not be a religious
believer in order to be a person of
integrity there's no question about that
but
can we sustain a culture of integrity
can we defend these ideals can we make
them meaningful for people including our
young people she's right to focus on our
young people they're our future
can we do all that
by cutting off the roots
by going silent about religion do we
have a way of defending our ideas of
honor and integrity on the basis of a
purely materialistic metaphysic
or an idea of man of the human as mere
material forces as as in a world
exclusively made up of efficient and
material
causation where there's no soul
where there's no
uh
sense of of a person as more than merely
the material i'm dubious about this i
have very grave doubts
about this john adams famously said
our constitution is for a moral and
religious people and will not serve well
any other kind of people that was not
controversial in adams day it's very
controversial in our day but even adams
knew that there were people who were
skeptical about religion who were
honorable people for sure what he was
doubting is what i'm doubting
whether you can cut
these concepts of integrity and decency
and honor off from their religious roots
in our culture or relegate them to the
merely personal and still and still
sustain them
in the face of the natural human desires
to gratify
one's own
needs to put oneself first
to
favor
oneself and one's comfort over others to
seek honor and glory and fame
and power and and influence how do you
fight back against all that if we cut
off the roots of our basic
understandings of moral concepts and
that's that's my word i mean i think of
the last word and the other atoms henry
adams is education education henry adams
that valedictory word shudder
yes exactly what do you do with the
death shutter what do you do with the
dread shutter what do you do with the
despair
shutter all of us shudder is
like faust and the realm of the mothers
and girls yeah
faust that that to be human is to
shudder to shudder in the face of
knowing you are on the way to extinction
in terms of your body to knowing that
you may be betrayed by friends knowing
that you may be trashed misunderstood
and misconstrued knowing you'll be lied
on rebuked and scorned and if religious
narratives at their best allow us to
come to terms with that sure you can't
deny it death if you escape and go to
disneyland sooner or later you're gonna
have to leave main street or orlando
come on back to your street and live
your life
so if you work through that shutter and
try to generate some spiritual
possibilities of learning how to love
learning how to have take risks learning
how to be vulnerable learning how to
have a certain kind of openness to
others and without those religious
narratives as a species we know that
they've been crucial but on the other
hand we also know that we're living in
very very secular times and and that
uh you know debate between t.s eliot you
can't make it without religious
tradition here comes chekhov saying not
only some of the best people i know are
not religious but religion has gotten in
the way it has promoted the hatred of
jews it has promoted the hatred of
non-christians it has promoted the
hatred of muslims with acquisit with
with with the uh
with the various crusades and so on so
how do you wrestle with that
set of issues in an honest way
and it's a tough one it's a tough one
you know we can make a case we can we
can
put things in terms of the dignity of
the human being as a
as a creature that is capable of
rationality and freedom of the will if
we continue to believe in those things
right but even stated in that way
uh it lacks the the compellingness
of the hebrew
religious human being is made in the
very image and likeness of of god of the
the of the supreme judge and ruler
uh of of of the universe having a
transcendent
significance something that goes beyond
the merely material beyond the
here and now now i mean if in fact the
truth is
that human beings are just atoms
molecules in motion just atoms have no
more significance than than a than a rat
or an ant then we have to face that
truth and do the best that we can with
it
but
you can have transcendence though
without the religious though well you
can have that i'm not sure about that
you could have transcendence beauty
democracy friendship you can have rich
friendship that transcends individuals
among seculars that takes no courses
outside of themselves that is
transcended in that sense but can you
give an account of that on purely
material if all human beings are it's
material stuff yeah no greater
significance than a rat or an ant
you can give no account of why human
beings should treasure friendships
should nurture friendship should never
betray a friend should make sacrifices
for a friend
should have integrity even at great cost
should be willing to sacrifice
themselves
you can ascribe significance to
friendship
even if you believe human beings are
nothing but these bundle of molecules in
the relationship without necessarily
referring to an external god all that is
to do is to not ask the question how is
this possible
assuming that there's no answer it's
just a secular source it's a secular
it's a secular source it's a paganism
it's aristotle's lucretius it's lucian
it's
even mark twain ends up very atheistic
but he's a spiritual being in his deep
voice
but he's living off the capitol and it
is rhetorical and metaphorical rather
than any kind of substance but yeah
no now as you know i'm a natural law
theory
i'm a that bucket christian so that i'm
just trying to think the strongest
position against my own position which
is the right way to handle it yeah
yeah yeah tell you what let's interrupt
that and let's hear from beck in
englewood california hi back
hi how are you thank you for taking my
call professor george and professor wes
here
is the bigger picture i'm very concerned
regarding a potential military conflict
between the united states
and north korea
here is the exact
question can you identify any person or
any group of people
that may have an acceptable
level of integrity and moral character
to carefully and
peacefully guide us away from any
potential conflict that can affect not
just the united states but the entire
world i'll hang up and i'll uh wait for
the answer thank you
thank you thank you back
gentlemen it's a very serious very
serious question
administration after administration has
tried to come up with a way of dealing
with north korea
and with the dictators of north korea
all have failed
um will president trump do any better
well we can only hope so but but so far
it doesn't look like he's going to do
any better
uh may do worse
uh this is a grave this is a grave uh
situation we have very little control
uh all we have been able to do so far is
to put pressure on china to put pressure
on north korea
that assumes that china is in a position
to put pressure on north korea we like
to believe that
and to some extent i think that is true
but i think it's limited
there's also the question of china's
will to put pressure
on north korea
that's very dubious
to me uh i wish i had a solution back i
wish i uh knew what to do yeah i can
think of i can i can think of people i
would trust
uh uh to manage the most difficult of of
of situations i have my own favorite
people in uh politics
uh but it would be an enormous challenge
for uh for anybody and so far the record
of administrations republican and
democrat
liberal and conservative has been a
record of failure
no it's true
it's a fundamental query i mean i wish
that
you know president trump had
more of the poise
and diplomatic maturity that we saw in
president obama and i'm not the one
who's been uncritical of president obama
i go at him tooth and nail but when it
comes to is the diplomatic maturity and
the use of language
in ways in which you try to lower the
temperature because this is an
all-or-nothing matter just a matter of
pushing buttons and lo and behold we're
in a completely different time in space
and zone here so that the kind of
childish narcissism that you get in the
hyperbolic rhetoric
of president trump as opposed to the
more mature diplomatic language of
president obama you have to acknowledge
that and that might be a way of lowering
the temperature but it's not a direct
answer to our dear sister's question
because i don't know of a set of
individuals who you could really trot
out to help mediate this thing i just
don't know of it you know we're our only
the only possibility anybody's come up
with is trying to work through
china china that's true that's exactly
right maybe south korea may have some
secrets
of of having connections with the north
on the down low and therefore be able to
surface but at the moment we do not have
an answer that question is a crucial one
in terms of impeding nuclear catastrophe
cornell west you met your first
president in 1968 who was it
my first president 1968. he wasn't
president at the time oh i met ronald
reagan when my brother one state meet
with our brother clifton west won the
state meet and the golden west is the
number one miler in the country went on
uc berkeley to say
i can tell you oh i tell you yeah ronald
reagan uh we got a chance to interact
with that brother he now he was a kind
and gentle person
but i was very close to the black
panther party very supportive angela
dave was upset with what he had done
with the angela day was pushing her out
of ucla as professor
and philosophy and so we had a nice
little dialogue about his uh
his views you're a teenager i was then
uh
14
14 but uh
but i've been raised by mom and dad to
treat people kindly even if i had deep
ideological disagreements have you ever
met donald trump
oh yeah i met donald trump absolutely i
met donald trump years ago in atlantic
city
and he was exactly the same way then
narcissistic insecure all spectacle very
little substance obsessed with being the
smartest and the richest in the room the
problem was that he was one of the few
white brothers in the room
so for the most part he had to keep his
mouth shut he was in there with mike
tyson
uh he had to keep his mouth shut because
uh we had a certain kind of predominance
of style that pushed him to the margin
but you could tell that he
still the same little uh nothing a
little with the same person who just
never grew up never grew up doesn't feel
as if he has any accountability
responsibility and stability anything
beyond himself
and i would have never thought if
somebody had told me then
that he would be in the white house
i would have told him to get off the
crack pipe
there's no way there's no possibility
that he would be elected by fellow
citizens
and lo and behold here we are in this
mess
it's worth asking ourselves
how how did that happen in there
to go around and the the neglect of
people who are
the trump uh supporters
it's a big part of that story can i tell
a story this uh
of course
brother cornell met ronald reagan long
before we knew we knew each other but
i'll tell you a little story about it
so one of my brothers uh happened to be
at a reception where he met former
president bill clinton
and he was telling me about this my
brother keith keith george from
charleston west virginia and uh
keith had keith had had a little
conversation with uh former president
clinton
and so i asked keith well how did how
did that go uh uh you keep strong
conservative like myself
uh so he said well you know what was
interesting is that he was so warm and
so engaging and
when he talked to me he made me feel as
though i was the only person in the room
and so i was reporting this story to
cornell i told it just as i told
to you and our viewers right now
and i said brother cornell isn't it
interesting these politicians they have
that ability they uh they they have this
knack for talking to people and and
making people like them and and make
them making people feel as though the
politician is talking to them and that
they're the most important person in the
world
and cornell replied uh saying
uh well
he said
i've met bill clinton on numerous
occasions
and he's just faking it with ronald
reagan it was real
bill clinton is a master at it he's a
master at it there's no doubt about it
but
by being a master he's able to
appear in a certain kind of certain kind
of way one of the things we like to do
on in-depth is ask our guests who some
of their influences are what are some of
their favorite books what they're
reading now here are the responses we
got from robert george and cornell west
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
here's a look at some of the best books
of the year according to amazon
edward luce chief u.s columnist for the
financial times argues that liberal
democracy is threatened in the retreat
of western liberalism
in the last castle denise kiernan
reports on biltmore house the largest
private residence in american history
tom nichols professor of national
security affairs at the u.s naval war
college argues that due to the spread of
the internet and 24-hour news expert
opinion is now being discounted in the
death of expertise
yuval harari looks at the future of
humanity in homo deus
and wrapping up our look at amazon's
best books of 2017 is buzzfeed's
scotchie cole's essays on her upbringing
as a daughter of indian immigrants in
canada one day we'll all be dead and
none of this will matter in my eighth
grade biology class our teacher gave us
a checklist of dominant versus recessive
alleles to teach us how babies come out
looking the way they do
the subtext from this particularly
nationalistic teacher cleared to me only
years later was that we would all end up
looking darker
and more vague than we did in the past
she wasn't exactly unhappy about it but
she did express some concern regarding
the eventual loss of the blue-eyed and
natural blonde
we were paired up with someone of the
opposite sex so we could compare genes
to determine what our potential child
would look like
let me really drive this home
a public school teacher in suburban
calgary told her teenage students to
pretend they were going to have sex with
each other and bear biologically likely
babies
i was one of the only ethnic kids in the
class my jeans were already steamrolling
everybody else's
my partner eric a white boy who was a
hollister t-shirt personified went down
the genetic checklist with me
when we arrived at hair on fingers or
knuckles i looked down at my hands for
what seemed like the very first time
standing up from the meat of my fingers
were soft black strands of hair
i was horrified
how had i never noticed such a grotesque
feature i always knew my legs were hairy
my arms covered my upper lip bristled
enough to catch flies
but i had overlooked this new barbarity
well i don't have any eric said looking
up at me while i hid my hands or the
desk
i nodded and said me neither
some of these authors have appeared on
book tv you can watch them on our
website booktv.org
a look now at some of the authors
recently featured on book tvs afterwards
our weekly author interview program
daily caller news foundation
editor-in-chief christopher bedford
explored the leadership skills of
president trump fbi agent tamara el-nuri
detailed his experiences fighting
terrorism as a muslim american and
former face the nation host bob
schieffer examined the role of the media
today
in the coming weeks on afterwards gold
star father kizir khan will recall his
immigration to the united states and
offer his thoughts on what it means to
be an american
christopher scalia son of the late
supreme court justice antonin scalia
will share selections from his father's
speeches and this weekend on afterwards
best-selling author jeanette conant will
report on the work of her grandfather
manhattan project scientist james bryant
conant there was a great fear that this
weapon was so powerful that it could
really destroy the world in the wrong
hands become something that terrorists
could use all of this was clearly
envisioned by its creators um
really before the war was over and they
began trying desperately to put in place
some kind of international controls so
that this weapon could not proliferate
you would not have people stockpiling
and building nuclear weapons left right
and center
and so this meeting in moscow in
christmas eve was so crucial because
my grandfather and the americans that
went were desperately hoping that they
could convince stalin and molotov to
agree to control the future of this
terrible terrible force
they were very optimistic
that it could still be done
but by the time they left moscow
they were
they were less convinced that the
russians really wanted to participate in
in these negotiations
afterwards airs on book tv every
saturday at 10 p.m eastern and sunday at
9 00 p.m eastern end pacific
here's a look at some books being
published this week
president trump's former campaign
manager corey lewandowski and citizens
united president david bossie provide an
inside look at the 2016 presidential
campaign in let trump be trump
in the doomsday machine whistleblower
daniel ellsberg responsible for the leak
of the pentagon papers reports on the
government's nuclear defense program and
shares his experiences as a defense
analyst
university of texas women's history
chair jacqueline jones recounts the life
of political activist lucy parsons in
the goddess of anarchy
also being published this week the
saboteur looks back at the life of a
french aristocrat turned anti-nazi
saboteur during the french resistance by
espn the magazine deputy editor paul kix
senior circuit judge on the u.s court of
appeals stephen f williams explores how
russian lawyer vasily maklikov attempted
to forge an alternative political path
and the leader to the 1917 russian
revolution in the reformer
and in the last man who knew everything
david schwartz recalls the life of
manhattan project physicists enrico
fermi
look for these titles in bookstores this
coming week and watch for many of the
authors in the near future on book tv on
c-span 2.
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that
[Music]
bye
[Music]
and we are back with robert george and
cornell west in our new york studio this
is our in-depth program and sean in
battleground michigan you have been very
patient please go ahead with your
question
actually battleground washington but
thank you for this wonderful opportunity
dr west i have in my hand a book that
you co-authored about 20 years ago
called the war against parents you
co-authored it with sylvia ann hewlett
dr west you referenced the scandi
scandinavian economic model
it's not a mystery what causes healthy
positive outcomes for children and
families they've been practicing in
scandinavia for years and years
the christian right and the libertarian
right have been marching arm and arm
with deregulation and de-unionization
policies that we know devastate poor and
working-class children and families
these families have been catching hell
now for the last 40-some years in this
country
when you have people like charles murray
writing books um like coming apart
attacking the poor and working class for
having poor moral fiber and you have
someone like speaker paul ryan who
claims to be a christian
he makes required reading ein rand's
atlas shrugged
it seems to me the christian rights god
is not jesus their god is a kind of
nietzschean
uh ein rand ubermensch entrepreneur type
who's who who epitomizes the kind of
petty bourgeois mentality i was
wondering could you explain sean we're
going to start with cornell west and
then robert george
oh no brother sean well he was on fire
he's laying it out there definitely
again
i think when you talk about the
christian rights certainly there is such
a thing there's a lot of danger in terms
of the hatred there the the contempt
that we see too often but it's not
homogeneous either there's a variety of
different voices there certainly is the
case
that not just the christian right but
the american right as a whole has such a
deep suspicion of government playing a
fundamental role in the lives of
everyday people that they can easily
overlook the ways in which government
intervention into the lives of everyday
people can be profoundly empowering as
opposed to simply be authoritarian and
repressive we have to keep track the
repressive effects of government
intervening but certainly when you look
to norway and finland and other places
we see the government we can look to
canada our beloved canada just
just north of the border the government
can play a very important role in
intervening into the lives of others to
enhance liberty to enhance well-being so
part of it is the ideological and a a
political question of perception and
will the christian right suffers from it
the secular right can suffer from it the
judaic right the buddhist right the
hindu right and so forth and so on but i
had great great fun writing that book
with my dear sister sylvia ann hewlett
who's going on to do magnificent things
in terms of
issues of inclusion at the corporate
level of women and peoples of color and
gays and lesbians and trans another
she's still going very strong with her
center for talent and innovation right
here in new york but that was over 20
years ago we wrote that war to book the
war against parents the ways in which
parenting is the ultimate non-market
activity in the market-driven society
brother other dissents uh sean's comment
was a highly theological one uh god kind
of detected a sort of dogmatism uh in it
uh i um i am not a fan of iron rand i'm
a very
strong sharp critic
of of iron rand
the whole of the christian right is not
randian most of the christian right is
not
not randy and i have my own criticisms
with some leading figures on the
christian right these days as you
as you might imagine
but
work done by charles murray by robert
putnam by david and amber lapp
and others on the cultural foundations
of
the moral collapse that we see not only
in minority communities and inner cities
and places like that
but in appalachia
in the south and old rust belt cities
among white working class communities uh
the the the the cultural foundations of
that are real and they've got to be
dealt with we go all the way back to
1965 when daniel patrick moynihan then
uh i think just a
young harvard professor who was working
as a assistant deputy secretary of labor
if i recall correctly
did his study that showed that the out
of wedlock birth rate among african
americans had risen to 25 percent and
one hand could see what the consequences
of that would be for this historically
persecuted and oppressed uh sector of
our society that that meant wide scale
fatherlessness and together with that
delinquency despair drug addiction
violence
incarceration in a in a vicious
cycle
when moynihan warned about all that
warned where it would lead
for his efforts he was labeled a racist
he was stigmatized and so people went
silent on cultural questions on the
cultural foundations of that uh family
collapse and uh and moral collapse for
fear of being treated the way moynihan
was treated and so a very significant
aspect of the part of the problem was
swept uh under the rug the one thing
moynihan i think was wrong about was he
thought it had mainly to do with race in
the history of racial oppression
uh we now know that that is too
simplistic
an account because we're seeing the same
effects happening where the family has
broken down for similar cultural largely
cultural reasons
in white working class communities and
in appalachia and in
other rural
areas now we can make the mistake also
of imagining that it's only culture that
economics has nothing to do with it uh
that other factors uh uh including uh
racism has nothing to do with it that
would be a mistake too but just as it
would be a mistake to leave those
factors out it's also a mistake to leave
these other factors out and you can
stigmatize murray and you can call him a
a racist he's a libertarian
i i'm a critic of libertarianism but in
his
recent work calling attention uh to the
disparities
between
the haves the wealthy and the have-nots
black and white and the cultural basis
and the importance of families and
especially intact families in
the success that people have as citizens
and as human beings he's doing a service
so is putnam so are the laps so are brad
wilcox and and other sociologists who
are finally calling attention to this
so my plea is just not to oversimplify
don't imagine that it's only culture but
don't leave culture out of it don't
shoot the messengers however much you
don't like them who deliver the message
when the message is right
i think just add one point you think
about
legacies of rabbi abraham joshua
heshamar and king malcolm x
accenting the moral lapse among elites
oh yeah the moral apps of wall street
the moral lapse of ivy league institute
the moral lapse of the journalistic
elites not our dear brother peter thank
god sister betty his beloved mother but
but we're talking about moral lapses
that cut across class they go up they go
down they go horizontal it's not just a
matter of focusing on the vulnerable
ones the coming apart the poor whites or
the poor blacks or poor browns or poor
reds and so forth this spiritual
blackout that we're talking about
cuts across every nook and cranny in
sight in ours
i think it also has to be pointed out
that while the spiritual consequences of
this moral collapse
are born most heavily
uh uh uh well the the spiritual content
consequences are really borne by
everybody the material consequences are
born mostly by the most vulnerable
absolute by the poor whether they're
black or white i agree
and and and
and
people are finally starting to call
attention to that problem one of the
things murray says in his new book
is
very often you see now
a rebuilding a successful marriage
culture lower divorce rates more family
formation
among educated and affluent elites
things seem to be going in the right
direction while things continue to go in
the wrong direction for poor and
working-class people so
murray says
it's time for elites to start preaching
what they practice don't preach moral
relativism when you're actually
practicing the moral virtues that are
leading to successful lives for
yourselves and your your children
and and working-class and poorer people
who often are devout religious believers
and who preach a message of family
integrity fidelity
uprightness need to
need to actually practice what
they uh they preach and i think there's
some some truth to that uh i i think we
need to call really on everybody
to lead the kinds of lives that will not
only
produce spiritual
value
but also make them materially
better off
from robert george's book conscience and
its enemies professor west he writes
the two greatest institutions for
lifting people out of poverty and
enabling them to live in dignity are the
market economy and the institution of
marriage
these two stand or fall together
yeah and i'm not sure that i certainly
would acknowledge the importance of
those two
very much so
but we'd have to first examine much more
closely what
kind of market economy we're talking
about what kind of marriage we're
talking about many marriages that
actually need to terminate because of
people catching hell the patriarchal
violence the indifference to callousness
and so forth one proceeds very
cautiously but certainly what what is
the quality of each one of those
categories that he puts forth i think
brother robbie would agree with that
that's one sentence out of the text the
question becomes okay now let's look at
the kinds of market economies that can
provide
the requisite
conditions for the flowering of our
fellow citizens and there's a variety of
different kinds let's look at the kinds
of marriages there's a variety of
different kind of marriages there's some
very ugly patriarchal marriages of abuse
that there's no way that the woman can
live a life of well-being you see and
i'm sure brother roberts will call that
into question so that would be the first
my first response to that particular
particular sentence my point is if you
destroy one of them you will destroy the
other and if you destroy both of them
then no one is going to
flourish uh i i'm not defending every
form of market economy i'm not deforming
or defending every uh every marriage uh
i've already uh said that i think the
problem with crony capitalism is that it
undermines the functioning of the market
absolutely it prevents the market from
doing what the market does well when
when it's properly functioning which is
it increases quality it lowers prices it
provides employment opportunity and
social mobility for those who are at the
bottom of the scale enables them to rise
when i say the market that's what right
that's that's what i'm interested in and
i want a culture in which
uh uh families uh uh function
to transmit the virtues
that children need in order to be
successful lives to lead successful
lives and be
contributing good
uh uh citizens that that's no in no way
to license abuse or
uh any of the other combinations
so i mean it's true that brother ravi
and i we really wrestle with the issue
of our uh
precious gay brothers and lesbian
sisters and trans because
there for example the very notion of
what some people call same-sex marriage
or a love that flows in which person of
the same gender
that brother robbie is always in our
dialogue been very
cautious and very careful in saying
as a christian
he still loves
gay brothers and lesbian sisters made in
the image of god
and so he's trying to stay in contact
with their humanity even as he is
critical of same-sex marriage is that a
fair characterization absolutely and
then the question becomes and i push him
on that because i i'm very much
uh one who who supports love flowing in
a variety of different forms even in
uh having legalized status when it comes
to gay brothers or lesbians sisters or
trans folk or whatever
and and there we get theological in
terms of what kinds of resources can i
pull can he pull and generate support
for his argument to generate support for
my argument and that's a serious matter
because there's certain biblical
passages that one can invoke that are
highly critical of same-sex sex marriage
uh there's crystal citrix crystal
centric understandings of of the
biblical text in which you focus very
much on jesus why was jesus silent on
the issue
if paul says
x paul says slaves be obedient to your
masters well we're not going to accept
that if paul says something about
same-sex marriage just we might accept
that those are the kinds of dialogues
that we have and i think those kind of
dialogues that we need to have in the
country
that begin with the preciousness of each
every one of us as human beings and then
move to
various ways in which we disagree
regarding the coming together in a
marriage or coming together in a
relationship or what have you yeah the
bedrock principle
is that of the profound inherent and
equal dignity of the human being right
oh my god
that's it
put it in religious terms the idea of
man made in the image and likeness of
god now in these uh areas of morality
and family my own arguments tend not to
be this i suppose would be typical for a
catholic be a different situation for a
protestant my arguments tend to be
natural law arguments philosophical
arguments not appeals to scripture i i
do think that scripture can enlighten us
i think it can uh that's true it's more
just protestants
that's right so it tends to be
essentially on the bench
where that tends to be absolutely made
more made more central
um
but the the fundamental issue for me i
mean the great majority of cases are
you're gonna you're you're gonna have
opposites opposite sex relations the
critical thing for me is that those
relationships be supported by a culture
that will enable them
not only to last but to provide the
milieu in which parents can transmit
essential virtues
that will enable their children to
resist all the terrible temptations that
can reduce them to narcissism
selfishness we're living in the wake of
the media this was our generation the me
generation whose motto whose slogan was
if it feels good do it well a lot of
young people of successor generations
have taken that
to heart and it's a very very bad
message
now how can we empower
men and women
to transmit to their children a
different message and to to inculcate it
in them in a way that will enable them
to resist the temptations to think that
what really matters in life is me me me
me me
money power influence wealth uh
so social standing status respect and so
forth
i mean the sad thing is that so many
children
in the last 30 years or so it reminds me
of philip larkin's thing about how my my
parents
mess me up it's the parents who've been
narcissistic the parents have been
indifferent the parents have been
callous and they passed that on to the
younger generation younger generation
has to find countervailing ways of being
in the world over against what their
parents transmitted to them you know
when we moved in the direction of uh no
fault divorce which was going all the
way back into the 60s uh actually
decent people thought this was going to
be a boon for everybody it would be good
for for the spouses because if they
weren't able to get along they could
separate and that that would be that and
there would be less fuss and bother and
less of a burden on the courts and on
the public uh
purse because the public purse supports
the courts and so forth and they even
thought it would be good for children
because it's got to be bad for children
living in
conflict situations with their with
their parents but if you look at work
that's done by uh
sociologists today again like people
like
the lapse and and others uh work on the
consequences of of no fault divorce
you know they it has not been good for
children
uh
children in most cases where there's not
violence or abuse even where there's a
high degree of conflict do better with
their parents sticking together but what
have we done to support marriages very
little what have we done to encourage
parents to stick together very little
what have we done to provide cultural
support
for parents to make it easier for them
to
sustain their marriages really very
little now this is not a critique of
government fundamentally because there's
very little that government can do here
other than get divorce policy right get
family law policy right the real work
has to be done by the institutions of
civil society it's got to be done by
those non-governmental institutions what
burke called the little platoons
family
extended family
uh church or other religious uh
community
neighborhoods civic groups uh
groups
in which people of different uh
ethnicities and faiths and so forth
support uh support each other that's
where the real work in supporting
marriage and the family has to be but if
the government did
help provide
jobs with a living wage quality housing
arts programs music programs sports
programs that channel the energies of
young people in such a way that it was
tied more to public interest rather than
just privatistic orientation that would
be a way in which like scandinavian
countries families could possibly be
sites where children would flower and
flourish
you certainly need those things now
whether the government should be the
provider of not the soul but can play a
partnership and a role in a fundamental
but part of the what the part of it
seems to be the way we do that is have
taxation at a rate that will enable
people to retain enough of their money
to be able to provide things like music
lessons and ballet lessons and religious
education and so forth for their for
their children also to put parents in a
situation where if they want to choose
private including religious education
you've been very good on this private
and religious education they're able to
do that and the situation now of course
is one in which you know people pay off
in property taxes to support public
schools even though they want to send
their own kids to religious schools and
it's
increasingly expensive even in the
catholic world in the old days when
priests and nuns did most of the
staffing of catholic schools you could
keep the cost down well the vocations
crisis in the catholic church now means
it's more difficult uh to do that the
costs of education become uh higher and
higher it's harder for parents to uh
afford to send their kids to
catholic schools so i i i think
government does have a role to play here
but often it is in facilitating rather
than in actually providing the services
and support that's that's needed i'd
rather see civil society liberated to do
that providing than to have government
come in and try to do it directly yeah
cornell west and robert george are our
guests here's a couple of their books
cornell west's best-selling race matters
first came out in 1993 brand new out
again this year for the 21st
25th anniversary with a new introduction
democracy matters came out in 2004 his
autobiography brother west living out
loud came out in 2009
black prophetic fire 2014.
here's a couple of robert george's books
including making men moral 1995 the
class of orthodoxies which we've talked
about today in 2001
conscience and its enemies 2013 and
conjugal union what marriage is and why
it matters we've done a little
discussion on that today as well
cornell west if somebody wanted to buy
one of your books which one do you
recommend to them i would tell them to
buy james baldwin to find next time
listen to some curtis mayfield and john
coltrane and nina simone there's so many
other voices more important than mine i
would never just promote my own text but
if they had a little extra time
i would say read race matters the new
introduction
robert george same question to you
uh
well i suppose it would it would depend
on a person's particular interest if
they're interested in the deeper sorts
of philosophical uh questions uh then
i'd recommend uh my my book making men
moral civil liberties and public
morality which is the subtitle of of uh
of of that book um that's the book on
the basis of which i uh was given tenure
at uh at princeton so it's kind of
special book it was my first uh first
book i i reread it uh recently and uh i
i still think i'm right about that
much of the rest of the academic
community thinks i'm wrong
about it
but found it found it interesting enough
to award me tenure uh if if people are
interested in contemporary issues
uh issues of marriage and sanctity of
human life and all the kinds of things
we've been talking about today then
perhaps my book conscience and its
enemies which shows my most recent book
would be
be the one to look at i've also written
with co-authors books on particular
topics so if people are interested in
abortion and euthanasia and fantaside
and those kinds of issues
i have a book that i've written with the
philosopher christopher tollefson called
embryo a defense of human life
and if people are interested in the
marriage issue i have a book that i
wrote with two of my former students
sharif girgis and ryan anderson a pair
of brilliant young men and that book is
called what is marriage man and woman of
defense
eric is in lutherville maryland
hierarchy
hi how are you
i have a question primarily for
for professor west but uh also
for the other professor as well i'm
trying to understand
the last eight years of the obama
presidency and he painted a very
progressive
agenda when he was running as a
candidate uh
never delivered on a large portion of
that progressive agenda
and i'm wondering whether
that was caused because the agenda
wasn't his real core beliefs
whether he lacked
the courage to
pursue those beliefs
or whether it was just the
dynamics of the political era that we're
living in
yeah i appreciate the question i think
one of the revealing moments of the
obama administration was march
2009 when he met with
leading wall street uh
heads of
firms there
and they told him
that they were wondering what he had to
say and he told them
i stand between you and the pitchforks
but i rest assure you
i am on your side i will protect you you
have little to worry about that's a
failure of nerve that's a spinelessness
it's a lack of courage
that that's what you tell poor people
that's what you tell working people
that's what you tell black people red
but you don't tell wall street elites
that i will protect you i am on their
side no accident not one wall street
executive went to jail given the massive
crimes that were committed in terms of
the predatory lending and insight of
trading market manipulation and
fraudulent activity so it was very clear
you'd have a wall street friendly
neo-liberal democratic party in power
and the same was true in terms of his
foreign policy when he preserved his
elites in
the state department and in the pentagon
so that the same folk tied to
drone strikes the ben the brendan's the
brennans and others remained in power
when he brought in tim geithner from
wall street he brought in my dear
brother larry summers smart as attack
but at the same time at that time tied
to deregulating neoliberal policies it
was clear he had wall street friendly
drone presidency escalating and
therefore a lot of the progressive
rhetoric and that audacity of hope would
become empty in regard to poor people
and working people symbolically he was
masterful
what i mean symbolically is that to have
a black face
in the highest place
in the american society empire and
government meant that not only we made
progress which we had but it was as if
black people were being empowered i mean
we got brother coats writing the book we
were in power for eight years and you
look around at poor people look around
the hood look around the ghettos look
around the schools look around at the
the the massive unemployment and the
mass massive incarceration you say wow
who was in power for eight years no
these black neoliberal middle class folk
were in power they're the ones whose
careers took off they're the ones who
did very well asked the poor people on
the ask the folk in prison asked the
folk in the hoods whether they were in
power
not at all there was a failure of nerve
not just about barack obama but among
intellectuals black intellectuals
became cheerleaders for barack obama the
same folk who talked about martin luther
king jr as the exemplar of justice
didn't want to talk about poverty the
same folk who talked about monitor king
jr as a great exemplar of justice
critical of vietnam and the bombs
dropped on the babies there didn't want
to say a word about the drone strikes
they were dropping on babies in yemen
and pakistan and so forth the same folk
even on the middle east
would want to talk about justice
consistently didn't say a mumlin word
when 550 precious palestinian babies
were killed in 50 days barack obama
didn't say a mumbling word either why
because he lacks courage he's spineless
he didn't want to tell the truth he's a
politician it was not in his interest to
speak about that kind of suffering you
see and so we ended up with another
politician rather than a visionary
leader now was he a good politician
absolutely got elected twice was he
better than john kane absolutely was he
better than who was the other brother
who read mitt romney absolutely but did
he fall short in terms of the standards
of the martin kings and others
absolutely and not enough people told
that truth
i'll let everyone in on a little secret
big business does not consider big
government to be its enemy that's judy
big business loves big government
exactly wall street loves big government
now upstart entrepreneurs don't
necessarily love big government small
business people don't love big big
government the big business
does because big business benefits from
government i'll tell you my own story
obviously doesn't have to do with
president obama whom i never met
um
but i was i served during the bush
administration as um
the second but george w bush on the
president's council on bioethics on a
number of occasions in relation to that
i was
uh in the white house uh advising him on
bioethical issues and we developed a
good relationship i have a lot of
respect for him um
he called me in though with uh two or
three other uh professors uh right at
the end in his last week
in office to talk about his memoir he
was already planning his memoir
so uh we were talking about his
uh eight years and
right in the front of his mind was
something that had just happened which
was the bailout of the big banks
the big bailouts
and unprovoked by uh by any of us he
just
said as if talking to himself almost he
said
you know i hated to do that i hated to
authorize that everything in me said no
you don't bring government in to bail
out businesses that have failed that
have failed because of their own
practices that's not the role of
government i'm a free market guy
and yet he said what could i do
the leading people on wall street and
the leading wall street representatives
like snow
in my administration are telling me that
if we don't do this
it will be a 1929 stock market
catastrophe what could i do i had to
authorize the bailout
wall street has tremendous
influence in any administration
republican or democrat they can be very
pro-market in theory pro-free market in
theory but if wall street wants a big
government intervention in the market
wall street's going to get it they can
be very progressive in theory
but if wall street wants something
wall street's going to get it it's very
hard to stand up against that and in
president bush's case i mean he did not
want to be the president who presided
over the next great
depression and he felt that his hands
were tied on this and he had no
choice wall street got what it wanted
free market guys
were not in favor of those bailouts my
free market friends were scandalized by
it and yet wall street wanted it wall
street got it the difference is that
president bush didn't put a figure
a representation of martin luther king
jr in the corner acting as if you're
working
on his project and based on his legacy
so it's more consistent even with
president bush as a conservative if
you're going to be
someone coming out of legacy of martin
king you're going to be courageous
sacrificial
service oriented for the week if not
just tell the truth i'm a neo-liberal i
might have a statue of him but i don't
have no plans of really following
through supporting the vulnerable i'm
not going to bail out main street i'm
not going to bail out the homeowners i'm
going to bail out wall street be honest
and we get a lot of black people who
have been moderate whitney young was not
mollusk king jr whitney young going to
run around act like he's malcolm x he
didn't run around act like he's
marvelous king jr he was whitney young
head of the urban league he was a
moderate so if you're going to moderate
say you're a moderate don't act like
you're some kind of progressive and
radical when you're really a moderate
that was part of my critique of barack
obama don't use martin luther king he
struggled too much he suffered too much
he paid the ultimate price quit
manipulating
his witness with neo-liberal policies if
you're going to get in trouble you're
going to follow martin if you want to be
moderate and adjust to the status quo
you're going to follow whitney young
just tell the people the truth
that's all that's like that's like
saying you show up at a concert acting
like you al green
and then you start singing like
like a brown version of pat boone or
something
tell people the truth this is who i am
quit lying about yourself this is the
thing that upsets me but not only that
but that's part of the best of the black
tradition robert havlin email
facebook twitter have become the new
non-state powers which have a huge
impact on societies worldwide they seem
to accelerate polarization and
disinformation
there's some truth in that i can't
contradict them him now now uh i also
spoke earlier about my my worries about
monopoly and oligopoly and especially
when it comes to civil liberties and
free speech issues when it comes to
these uh these types of firms and
platforms
um
but uh i think
that people who care about the quality
of our civic discourse
can use those platforms to counteract
the bad things that this gentleman
rightly points to
i in my uh in my own uh work use
facebook as a kind of ongoing seminar
uh i uh i have serious discussions with
facebook friends of serious uh issues
uh i call to the attention of my friends
things that i think are worth reading
when i say my friends these are mostly
people i've never met in my life but
they're people with whom i've developed
uh relationships uh online because
they're interested in the kinds of moral
and political civic uh religious issues
that that i'm uh interested in so my
advice uh to the gentleman is let's make
the most of facebook it's not gonna go
away facebook and twitter are gonna be
here we're not gonna get rid of them now
there may be some steps that we can that
that we that we can take to make them
behave a little bit better than they are
behaving but we ourselves in using those
uh uh assets uh can use them to
counteract the bad things and to advance
things that uh would improve the quality
of our civic life absolutely i mean you
think for example the great
reverend william barber the second
who's reviving the poor people's
campaign right now when he uses this new
technology
it's a way of reaching out across race
and class and gender and sexual
orientation to bring people together
that's qualitatively different than
the neo-nazis who we were staring down
in charlottesville just a few months ago
who used the same technology
to bring together
the fascist crypto fascists and others
to try to bring some kind of
contentious
attitudes toward blacks and jews and
muslims and palestinians and gays and
lesbians and catholics and others even
though david duke is a catholic in the
clan but clan began probably as
anti-catholic that's up with mobility
american style you see get a catholic
head of the ku klux klan my god so you
so somebody will have a negro head
i did see a black person who marched
into charlottesville
who marched with the nazis with the
nazis
the negro had the world's flag that's
very complicated there's confusion
everywhere confusion everywhere very
much so but generally speaking it
reflects who we are as persons
sort of the bastardization the the the
the division and so forth that's what we
bring to the technology if we haven't
undergone some pi day prior to what yeah
that's a brain then that's going to
reflect it's going to be reflected
that's exactly right supriya is in
edgewater new jersey please go ahead
with your question or comment
hi thanks so much it's been great
listening to both of you i'm really i
feel
more than just informed by this
conversation and
educated but
i feel
my heart is healed a little bit and so i
want to echo
the calls from others to
figure out a way there is a way
and i know
professor george i think you said you'd
been you know kind of wrangling with
this issue of bringing your seminar to
the public et cetera but um
there is a way and
much more creative minds than i can
figure it out
but we got to get you on television and
we got to get this out because
um i think the way that you both go
about having these discussions
disagreeing with each other and the
obvious affection that you have for each
other is really important so having said
that let me get to my question which is
going back to
a framework that you
brought up earlier you were discussing
earlier for how this sort of american
experience or experiment
works with these three sort of
elements right we have the free markets
we have
the foundation of virtuosity and we have
uh sorry a second pillar of um democracy
and
i guess my question is how in the world
where do we begin when
i think what's become so obvious to so
many of us in the last year
we have some really deep problems in all
three of those areas
you know i mean i i've been spending the
last year trying to figure out where to
focus my attention and i'm one person of
millions who's doing the same exact
thing
question is where do we begin
um is there a chicken or egg kind of
situation here or
are there things that we can be doing
um
thank you for your time today let's hear
from the professors who wants to start
this job
well supriya thank you very much not
only for your kind comment but for your
very thoughtful uh uh question and it's
it's it's the right question
uh i've wrestled with it myself here's
the best i can do
i think all of us can do a service to
all of the rest of us
by reaching out
to people whom we know have a very
different perspective on basic issues
than we have
so if you're not a trump person and
especially if you're someone highly
critical of trump or someone who's
afraid of trump
get to know a trump voter
get to know them not just to lecture
them
not not just to harangue them but to try
to understand where they're coming from
i think that would be a service if
you're a trump person if you're a trump
voter
and you think
that
that trump is the tribune of the people
to stand up against these horrible
elites get to know one of those horrible
elites you know reach out in a personal
way
uh and just just listen one of the
things we need to do one of the great
things with brother cory i mean i i love
listening to this cat so you know it's
easy to listen so and and and listening
is where it it begins and i think
sending a signal across the
ideological or partisan design divide
that i'm willing to listen is the
necessary
first
first step i mean we're badly divided in
this country we're deeply deeply
polarized it's not the first time this
has happened we go back to the election
of 1800 certainly look at the civil war
look at the division over slavery
but it's still you know even considered
against that historical backdrop this is
a period of deep
polarization animosity resentment
americans resenting other americans
americans thinking of other americans as
villains
large numbers 62 million thinking of 62
million as villains with the other side
thinking of the first 62 million as as
villains if this precious experiment in
republican government and ordered
liberty is going to survive we're going
to have to get past this and it begins
with talking with each other and you
can't talk to someone else across that
kind of divide unless you signal to that
person a willingness to listen so let's
begin there it seems to me absolutely i
think what one begins with oneself
because one on the one hand has been
shaped by traditions in the past we
critically appropriate the best we hold
it arms when length the worse but also
you attempt to exemplify in your
thoughts in your actions in your
organizations in your networks the kind
of truth-telling witness brain but also
more than that and this relates to
present-day music again because you see
robbie and i grew up in a time in which
you had tenderness and sweetness and
kindness
shot through
your music
you had groups that could sing not just
in tune but touch the soul at the
deepest level they weren't just
titillating the body these days the
music intimidates the body in order to
make money as opposed to shaping the
souls in order to make persons stronger
to make persons spiritually equipped and
and ready to take on the world curtis
mayfield didn't sing just to make money
he equipped people of all colors to deal
with the crisis and catastrophes with
smile style humor
that's what's missing we need all of
that in our own lives we need that in
movements and left-wing movements
centrist movements where is the humor
that allows us to laugh at ourselves
such that we can grow and thereby be
better relative to who we are because
some people going to be who they are
everybody is who they are not somebody
else right no everybody's not going to
agree with you but you can touch them
you can unsettle them but if they shut
down before you even get a chance to
touch and unsettle
then we even more divided in that way
you see and robbie and i i mean we we
brothers for life
and we're gonna fight we gonna struggle
and so forth and so on you see but at
that human level that's just the way it
is no matter how unpopular we become or
whatever they ain't about on popularity
it's about the kind of human beings we
choose to be before the worms get our
body
that's the kind of tradition we come
from that's kind of people we come from
that's the making not just for the
country of this country that's true for
every other country america has no
monopoly on integrity they gotta lift
away and you it courage in turkey and
the jews got in tel aviv and the
palestinians got it on the gaza bank if
they are willing to be courageous you
got the same cowardice in each place
so in that sense it's really a human
thing most of human history is a history
of domination and hatred that's what it
is all we're trying to do is interrupt
it we're trying to disrupt it you know
when you're talking about curtis
mayfield i'm thinking hank williams oh
hey
he's he's a genius on the vanilla side
of town that country music soulful to
the core but different kind of twang
different kind of rhythm different kind
of drum beat
but very similar story
connected bob marley imitating the both
of them in in jamaica with his genius
you know one of the things we tend to do
uh supriya
is we we we try to signal things to each
other especially others in a group that
we're already comfortable in uh to to
make clear that we're in the in group
we're on your side
uh we we we say things especially saying
things about other people with different
beliefs
that are meant to strengthen our bond
with people in our tribe
well i think we need to be willing a
little bit to be the gadfly in the tribe
do what brother cornell has done so well
on the progressive side you know
question some of these established
orthodoxies don't worry so much about
signaling that i'm an insider and i'm on
the uh part of the incredible be a
little willing to
take the risk of being an outcast and if
and if and if you're made an outcast
that's just something that we're going
to have to we're going to have to live
with it's much better to have integrity
it's much better to try to do something
to reform a situation badly in need of
reform than to just live with the
comfort of being in the in crowd by
saying what other people want to hear
have you ever been criticized for your
friendship with cornell west and vice
versa
very rarely in my case one of the i have
to hand it to my
conservative
friends
very rarely has
i think that one exception would be on
issues having to do with israel
where
cornell has been perceived by some
conservatives as going over the line
right too harshly critical of israel now
i know
in my heart there is not
anything anti-semitic about cornell west
he's he's got a heart for the
palestinian people and they're suffering
he wants to see
uh justice done we would have some
disagreements about israel israeli
policy uh
but no government and and and i want all
my friends who who share my uh support
for israel to understand
there's no government that should be
immune from criticism there's no
government that doesn't make mistakes
israeli government has made a mistake
the the netanyahu government has made
mistakes they've done things that are
wrong
nobody is perfect so those criticisms
are perfectly legitimate now there are
people and this is what's causing the
sensitivities i think there are people
who go over the line who use criticism
of the israeli government of the state
of israel as a pretext for expressing
anti-semitism there are people who would
like to see israel disappear from the
face of the earth i believe it's still
in the palestinian charter isn't it
cornell i'm not sure but i believe it's
still in the palestinian charter that
israel should cease they've shifted
you know so i think that's caused the
sensitivities that in some circles have
led people to say how can you robbie
george is a strong supporter of israel
and jewish people
uh
uh associate with cornell west now other
if people who know me also know
that i have been one of the leading
voices i think it's fair to say you
correct me if i'm wrong cornell uh on
the christian and the conservative side
in defending the rights of muslims
i i i made that a big part of my work
when i was part of
supporting our muslim brothers and
sisters that's exactly right does that
on the local level you asked the local
muslim
leaders there in new jersey and so no so
i think we need to avoid tribalism of
any of of any sort here but apart from
that i i'm really proud of my
conservative friends who who who really
have seen value in the work that cornell
and i do
they have great respect for this man by
the way great respect for him have you
been criticized for your friendship oh
sure though you know the leftists tend
to be a bit more vociferous than the
right-wing brothers when it comes to
that number of them said we all
understand why you spend time where his
stance on same-sex marriage we wrestle
on abortion issues we wrestle on issues
of it this extended regulation and so
forth and uh and i just tell them i say
one when you don't understand who he is
as a human being
you have a stereotype of him you
understand a conservative and then think
that somehow by some law of transitivity
you can grasp his complexity because he
calls himself a conservative well every
conservative in a stereotypical sense is
in no way
a human being who is conservative it has
a variety of different complexities
orientations that don't conform to the
stereotype so i just tell them up front
you never met the brother
won't you come to dinner with us why
don't you come to lunch with us have a
drink with us have some coffee with it
well he doesn't drink that but i don't
have my cognac but uh but the absolutely
in that sense i know that and it's the
same since when he tells them he said
well brother west says that if there was
a palestinian occupation of jewish
brothers and sisters he would be saying
exactly the same thing against
palestinian occupation that he says
against israeli occupation it's a
consistent moral and spiritual issue
palestinian baby has the same value as a
jewish baby and vice versa innocence on
both sides humanity on both sides how do
we proceed we can disagree on tactics
and strategies we've got to make sure
our spiritual and moral foundations are
in place so it is a brother robby
brother robbie now we went to dallas for
brother flowers terry flowers that's
exactly phillips academy it's all black
uh uh uh precious young people there and
his engagement not just at the personal
spiritual level but also in terms of the
framework that he provided in terms of
pidea that's empowering to them he's the
only vanilla brother in the room
but the human connection is made flowers
is visionary leadership makes a
difference absolutely fantastic i need
to tell your viewers about this school
in dallas texas
doctor and mrs flowers it's a labor of
love on their part they have no public
funding whatsoever they take children of
prostitutes drug addicts kids who you
think are lost they have no future
they're going to end up in jail they're
going to end up in trouble they take
these kids and they give them a first
class education i don't even know how
they do it cornell but they do what i
love they do i know why they do it how
they pull this off and the kids end up
going to notre dame and baylor and
stanford and good universities
all over the world but you got
virginia's like erica badu her kids go
there yeah she's one of the greatest
artists of our time so you got a variety
of different kids there
all
beautifully black
and brown
and yet that love is there and harlan
crowe actually has made a contribution
as you know he has indeed he was very
grateful
to their great but who is harlan crow
he's come up several
he's a very generous donor to many many
uh good causes including the school that
the that the flowers uh run for for
black kids in uh
uh in dallas it's it's it's wonderful to
see the kids are there in their school
uniforms and they're they're being
taught not only uh classroom uh skills
but just the the human skills that's
right uh the the the rules of poly tests
self-respect respect for others
self-respect congeniality
how you're sensitive to other people's
needs all those things that go into the
making
of any human being of integrity at the
end of the day this is a retail
operation isn't it soul craft is a
retail operation you know it's working
with individual kids it's somebody a
parent a teacher a coach a grandparent a
pr a pastor working with individual
kids i just got a message from my
producer that says you can just go home
it's cool they got this
i think you're right
jim
pine ridge south dakota you're on
cornell west and robert george
good morning gentlemen
uh i have a question
to both of you
hey jim you got to turn down the volume
on your tv there's a little bit of a
delay why don't you go ahead hit the
volume and just go ahead and state your
question we can hear you
my question to both professors is
what are your thoughts about rewriting
the u.s constitution to make it truly
more equal
for all peoples
thank you
thank you jim very much
the u.s constitution
i rather like the one we have now uh uh
i i
do think that uh from time to time
reconsidering
elements of the constitution uh it's
important the constitution itself
provides methods more than one by the
way
for its own amendment so it contemplates
the possibility of improvements uh being
made
but um
i think the fundamental structure of the
constitution
uh
is a work of extraordinary genius
uh and we would we'd be making a bad
mistake if we threw over things like the
separation of powers
the concept of the national government
is a government of delegated and
enumerated and therefore limited powers
in the states of government as
governments of general jurisdiction
exercising uh plenary uh authority
federalism
um uh there are i think crucial uh
dimensions of our of our bill of rights
that i wouldn't want to see touched now
jefferson thomas jefferson believed
that the dead hand of the past should
not control the living so he wanted to
have a new constitutional convention uh
every 20 years so what his sense of what
a generation would be uh i don't think
that would be a good idea the the
founders with this constitution have
given us a way of preserving something
that would
before that time uh
impossible to preserve which is
republican government government not
only of the people which all government
is and not only for the people which all
good government is even if it's a benign
despotism but this rare thing government
by the people
our problems have not come
from our constitution or from our uh
excess of fidelity to constitutional
principles our problems whether it's
racism
no matter what it is have been a lack of
fidelity to our constitutional
principles had we honored the
declaration's principle that all men are
created equal
we would have done away with slavery
from the very beginning we wouldn't have
had jim crow we wouldn't have had
segregation the problem wasn't the
principle it was our failure to live up
to the principle the same is true with
the separation of powers the same is
true in so many other areas
an area that i'm concerned about is
the seepage of legislative authority off
to the executive branch and the agencies
on the one side and off to the courts on
the other side congress does everything
but legislate
and take responsibility and be
accountable for legislation we're
governed not by our elected
representatives we're not governed by
ourselves through our elected
representatives we're governed by people
we've never heard of in bureaucratic
agencies and we're governed by courts on
crucial issues so i want to see fidelity
i want to come back to the
constitutional principles that we have
we don't need new ones we need greater
fidelity to the ones we have
there's a wonderful book i just read
called in the shadows of the american
century written by a brother named
alfred mccoy
and he makes the point that to live in
an empire
in which the executive branch
eclipses the others in terms of its
ability to engage in prerogative
activity to do things with little
accountability people have called this
the imperial presidency yeah but it's a
presidency that goes hand in hand
with an imperial america we got what
587 bases in 42 countries and 140
special operation activities around the
world you see so we are in that sense a
kind of empire in a very real way and
the question becomes can government by
the people for the people and of the
people survive in the face of an empire
with military overreach corruption of
elites a culture driven by market
sensibilities unconcerned about the
centrality of public life common good
and a rule of law that can be undercut
by big money
now that's a serious situation and i
think it requires more than just a
rewriting of a constitution it has to do
with the kind of people we are
the marvelous constitution that we had
was still a pro-slavery document for
over 80 years
the marvelous constitution after the
1880s was still very much a pro
monopoly capitalist
constitution in which poor people when
the workers get the right to vote i mean
to engage in collective bargaining the
eighth the 1930s
it took that long argentina had it in
the 1830s and argentina is not known to
be on the cutting edge for social
justice they were a hundred years ahead
of us when it came to our working people
women voted when 1919 1920. so that the
same constitution with persons who are
not prepared to fight for working and
poor people can be used on behalf of the
wealthy or on behalf of everyday people
would you accept that brother uh
parts of it probably part
that's right
i'm less inclined to see our
our military as an imperial um
we've been an empire though since well i
mean you know we we
men like my father joseph george uh
uh my father-in-law uh irvingstrom
marched over to germany and and and they
defeated hitler and they came home that
was grand and they came and they they
didn't occupy they weren't like the
roman legions they weren't like caesar
uh you know they they they defeated the
the the nazi tyranny and they they came
home and they handed to the german uh
people a democracy they handed to the
japanese people uh a uh a democracy so i
think that the picture's
complicated and i do think we need to be
i need i think we need to be respectful
to our military i think we need to be
respectful to our veterans
um
you know a lot are feeling disrespected
these days and and that's that's right
that's not that's that's not good i
think all of us as americans should
acknowledge whatever mistakes we have
made when it comes to their militaries
they're following the rulers and they're
the courageous ones willing to put their
lives on the line but it's the rulers
who often too often don't have the kind
of vision
required
relative to the courage of the ordinary
soldiers in the country yeah
let's hear from hassan in carmel valley
california hi hassan
hello good morning it's an honor to be
uh on your show um mr west put it the
best
if we didn't have c-span i'm not sure
what would have happened to us
i
i
see that during the whole talk you two
gentlemen are talking about truth
telling
and the role of the family
and i think my question is
what kind of
parents
would you suggest you would be or your
neighbors or your friends would be when
they talk to their kids about sources
the main sources of of the human uh
problems right now
uh isis
and and the force of religion
uh in our in our culture in in this
country
the isis actually when they chop off a
reporter's head or someone they arrest
believe it or not they call it
ibrahim they call it abraham tradition
so see their hero is this of abraham
that is revered by
muslims and jews and and christians
so if we introduce this man as a hero to
our kids
then of course we will have
people like isis of course we will have
failed states like iran pakistan
israel sudan
afghanistan all these countries are
failed institutions fail states
and i guess please bear with me because
you encourage
your viewers to talk about the truth so
this is my version of the truth that
we have to face the fact
that these failed institutions judaism
and islam are failed institutions
and
all right hassan i think we got your
point we're almost out of time gentlemen
we have
three minutes for that question i think
we need to be very truthful with our
children about all things
and uh when it comes to religion uh the
truth is that some of the greatest most
heroic most generous things that have
ever been done have been done
on the basis of religious motivation and
in the name of god
but the other side is some of the most
dastardly horrible things that have been
done have been done
on religious motives and in the name of
god isis
does act in the name of god and as far
as we can tell
that is sincere it's horrible
it's unjust
but these people
religious fanatics
sincerely believe they're doing what god
wants so there's no guarantee of justice
just because you're doing it on
religious motivations now the rest of
the truth is
some of the most horrific deeds ever
done in human history have been done
on a secularist motivation the great
tyrannies of the 20th century that are
responsible for the highest death tolls
of any regimes in human history were of
validly secularist regimes the nazis and
the and the communists so i don't think
it's fruitful uh to uh to try to to draw
up a grand balance sheet and say on the
whole religion is good or on the whole
religion is bad but to recognize that
good things can be done in the name of
religion and bad things can be done in
the name of religion let's try to do
good things and avoid bad things when
when it comes to what i think we should
all agree is the best in religion the
idea of the dignity of the human person
jews and christians understand the
person made in the image and likeness of
god other traditions may have a
different way of of articulating the
basis of that dignity but still
when we focus on religions teaching that
all human beings have dignity and worth
and are not reducible to the status of
ants or
or or or
or or rats then we will do good things
then we will honor people then we will
practice virtue
and in fact i think we're just talking
about the history of the species
that when edward wilson at the end of
his career he talked about what do we
need he's social biologists evolutionary
theorists we need something to push back
our egotism our tribalism we need
universal visions in which people can be
brought together focusing on the most
vulnerable well that's what is the best
in many ways in both religious and
secular traditions most of human history
is a history of mendacity criminality
hatred envy contempt domination
exploitation how do we disrupt it and
you're only disrupted by keeping alive
traditions of love
of love of truth beauty goodness
and enacting that love it with body mind
soul group network organization and
democracy is one of these very difficult
efforts to fuse a love of truth and
goodness and beauty so that it might
disrupt a longer human history of
domination but we know imperial
democracies have their own forms of
domination so they're incomplete they're
unfinished but in the end you got one
life to live biographically what are you
going to do in relation to your own love
of truth and goodness and beauty and how
would be how it be connect how will it
be connected to to others involved in a
similar question can i say something to
parents based on my 30 now 33 years of
of teaching at princeton and that is
this parents please
care as much care more
about the integrity of your children
care more about their character care
more about who they are as human beings
than you do about whether they get into
williams or yale or princeton or ohio
state or wherever it is and go on to
harvard law school or go on to goldman
sachs or something like that
we're right as parents to care about the
professional futures and the material
futures
of our children we're white to encourage
them to aspire to be persons of high
standing and and and make good incomes
and so forth that's very important i'm
not denigrating that
but what's more important than that is
character and integrity and that's where
your real focus as parents needs to be
absolutely
robert george of princeton
cornell west of harvard
thank you for being on book tv pleasure
oh thank you so much for that
indeed indeed indeed
thank you so much